three two
hey everyone this is gm josh frida uh
today i'll be
commenting on this select chess
invitational uh run by the
st louis chess club um so it's about
it's going to start in about a minute
and a half i'll be commenting on these
games it's a 15-0
rapid uh event on lee chess
five rounds one minute between the
rounds so
gonna be a pretty rapid pace um
and yeah we'll see how things go
so um yeah so as far as some of the
players go
uh we have
so we have aaron's son is um
aaron lynn and sandro argonaut
is alexander lashville
chess logic is alex zhang
who's our number one seed
and casual player is
aradya panda so as you can see we have a
pretty big range from 2300 leeches
rating at least which again
a lot of these guys are provisional and
it's it's rapid so the rating doesn't
always mean that much
but a bunch of people who haven't played
rapid on here before so it should be an
interesting tournament we'll see how it
goes
should be started about 10 minutes i'm
going to jump around a little but i do
my own commentary style tends to be i
like to stick to games for a little
while so that it's not just constant
jumping i find that to be kind of
annoying
so we'll see uh where it takes us so i
guess we'll start
with um oh we have uh someone else who
oh we have someone with a buy that's why
okay so let's see let's who should we
start with um
i suppose we'll go with
which game are we gonna go with it's
always these decisions to make you know
um let us go with
maybe sandro argonaut try this one
so this is sandra argonaut as white
against chess logic
who is black so we have a london system
uh black chooses a kind of queen zinnian
set up against it which is one of the
ones which it makes a lot of sense
so there are definitely quite a few
options you have so white black goes for
d5 the other one
is to try to go with c5 takes and put a
pawn on d6 and go for a hedgehog type
structure
both of them of course are perfectly
legitimate ways of playing
black instead chooses to go with d5 so
usually with d5 the idea is it allows
you to put your bishop on a more active
square d6 which you see black does
so you see both players are playing
relatively fast it's still early in the
game
one of the things i would say is that
it's 15-0 so falling behind on time too
much can be a real problem
because if you get very low there's no
increment to kind of keep you alive
so time management in these games is
going to be really crucial you'll notice
white does another typical maneuver
rather than trading the bishops puts a
knight on e5 to maybe cement it with a
move like f4 sometimes although i would
say that here
you have to be very careful because if
you allow a knight into e4 followed by
f6
you might find that this knight is
actually not such a strength and in fact
i might have played if i were black
white here i might have tried knight
here first
just to kind of avoid this sort of
scenario although honestly it's probably
both are fine
um and in fact black does play with this
way
so i don't know allowing f6 with
especially with this kind of structure
um like that bishop on g3 is actually
not that great so as a move like f6
maybe just knight d7 eventually playing
with c5
might end up being quite good for black
here but again it's still kind of early
in the opening
uh plenty of things happening so it's
not like anything too significant is
going on
i guess we can check other games again
it's just the opening so i don't
want to linger too much oops that's a
little weird
didn't update uh let us see so
we have other games we're going to try
to find with a bit more action going on
and then i'll switch back to maybe this
one
so let us see um
say this game actually has some interest
so this is aaron sunboy
against st louis n6 so aaron sumboy is
black so in this position we have a kind
of hanging pawns position which is
fairly typical
but we have a bishop here which is not
typical usually this bishop is actually
back here
trying to support the knight trying to
support the pawns but the advantage of
having the bishop here is that sometimes
you can create counter play by putting
pressure against the knight so for
example something like queen out here
sometimes even 94 type moves can come
into play
uh but of course you have to be very
careful and i would say that white's
bishop is extremely active along this
diagonal
which is not always something that's so
pleasant so the key with the hanging
pawns is first of all you have to make
sure they don't hang
which i guess goes in the name but you
also have to make sure that these pawns
um
eventually can sometimes become a
strength if if you for example threaten
d4 opening up your bishop at some point
these pawns can be quite strong so it's
really kind of a question of
how you're able to use them but i would
say that with the hanging pawns you have
to play very actively
so for example a move like this i'm not
usually that crazy about because i'm not
sure the bishop the queen wants
to be here first of all um but second of
all it's just not that active so
normally the queen likes to be a square
like this maybe even e6
is a good square for the queen in these
positions because it holds on to your
center nicely
but in this case i want to use my bishop
here so i would actually consider queen
out here with the idea of taking this
knight and maybe putting my net on e4
and playing very very actively in that
manner uh the queen on c7 i'm not
a huge fan of so white goes a3
probably again you should take this
knight and put a knight on d5 on e4 i
think you have to play
uh quite actively here i'm not crazy
about the move a3 i would have maybe
tried um
maybe fixing the bishop even a move like
bishop f4 is is a playable option but
you had quite a few options even moving
this knight was not so stupid
um but i definitely think that black
should think about taking this knight
but what i do like is that both players
seem to be weighing their decisions but
not playing too slowly
i actually just commented for another
event believe it or not and in that
event i would say one of the sections
particularly the k
through 6 section the players just play
so blindingly fast and they even add
increment
um but they were just missing kind of
everything so i think these guys are
playing at a nice deliberate pace which
i think is
is very good so yeah taking the knight
is sensible because the bishop here
would be kind of bad
and then bringing the knight in so this
forks the bishop and queen
obviously the queen is going to move and
then the question is do you want to take
the bishop
it seems obvious that you want to take
it and i think here you probably should
but there are situations where taking
the bishop
the bishop's not even that great of a
piece whereas this knight is quite good
so it's kind of a decision to make the
queen goes back to c2 which i think
makes sense
so yeah here probably you should take
and then of course the maid is
threatened so you bring the knight here
to guard against the mate
and also guard your center but i would
say that black has to be careful not to
simplify too much
because then these pawns become weaker
the more pieces come off the board but i
would say that with the knight on f6
bishop on b7 the rook's coming to the
center maybe rookie 8 rook d8
ideas of d4 i think that black should be
not too unhappy here
but you have to be very careful uh of
course about your pawns suddenly
becoming hanging
so i suppose we can move to another game
uh let us see what's happening
so this one uh casual player is
white uh one of the higher rateds in the
event
uh at least again it the rating doesn't
mean that much because a lot of them are
unrated
so in this game it looks like black has
these very strong pawns i'm curious how
this happened
so it was an exchange french
and white's just playing very simply
developing pieces black is kind of doing
the same
um but black black's the one who planet
plays more aggressively here
with knight boom to e4 notice how white
lost some time also by doing this
and then takes so this is the kind of
thing that can get you into trouble
seemingly from out of nowhere
because in this position if you just
castle or play h3
or do something like this you're kind of
playing normally this is not a bad way
to play
but if you do this you have to be
careful because here if you take you've
actually just lost
to tempe and even in a position with
like an exchange french which is a
relatively safe structure for both sides
losing two tempe is a big deal so i
would say that this is
probably not a wise decision by white
and now with f5 coming in i really like
this idea
trying to put the pawn on f4 i think
this is just really problematic
um the pawn and f4 just looks like it's
going to be so nasty
so white plays here i mean i would even
consider trying moves like
like trying to like f3 of course f4 is
bad but something like f4 just trying to
stop
up those pawns it takes queen takes i
don't think there's any tactics on the
bishop
and f4 is a very hard move to play
because you are allowing this really
beautiful pawn structure for black but
sometimes the pawns pushing is is even
more of a threat so i think after here
already it's a difficult position uh he
grabs the bishop but honestly i don't
know how much that helps and here i
think black's white's just gonna get
horribly attacked
because these pawns are so strong f3 is
in the air probably white has to play f3
themselves
and after here just bite the bullet and
bring the bishop back because
the idea of black playing f3 just looks
so powerful
so white does indeed do this e3
um and then g5 so here
it's just one of those positions that
can be really difficult to play but i
would say that black has to be a little
careful if white gets the bishop out so
the white does something i really like
and maybe black shouldn't have allowed
it like g5 doesn't seem necessary to me
like i would consider even a move like
rook here
or maybe just fixing this knight this
knight's not doing a lot i would
consider
rerouting the knight somewhere a little
bit better maybe from e7 it can go to f5
maybe to d5
but by doing this you allow this and now
this bishop which previously was not so
great has a beautiful
square on c3 and you'll notice the
black's own king is actually not that
it is not that amazing i still like
black's position kind of but i would say
that it's it's all of a sudden become
really unclear so white's done a really
great job regrouping
i think this this idea was really nice
so why don't we stick with this game i
think it has the potential to be
to really heat up and have a lot of
action
um
so what else have we got here
um
yeah probably the queen should move here
and again black's idea is actually like
it's funny because this bishop looks
very strong but just by itself it's not
going to do that much so probably black
should just be trying to shove on the
on the king side where the advantage
lies so something like queen here maybe
just playing
here black decides to play this which is
a little surprising um
so obviously white has to be careful
maybe a move like king h1 is kind of
prudent at some point just so this queen
can move
uh because obviously you don't want to
walk into this check normally although
even here the funny thing is after queen
d3
e2 check there is this move uh so white
decides to do it this way instead
uh which is also quite reasonable i
would say
but the idea is the queen wants to move
here where it's gonna kind of
put a little pressure on black's
position and kind of say
uh you're not the only one with the
threats my guy
um but definitely very double-edged c6
is a move i don't like i don't like
cutting your queen off i believe that
the queen is just better
on the king side uh to keep safeguarding
the pawns to kind of keep everything
nice
i think a move like c6 asks for trouble
and i think after a move like queen d3
i'm already starting to like white
uh i don't like taking though i thought
after queen d3 though because if checked
the king can simply move
uh and the problem is that after queen
d3 the knight can't really move either
because you're threatening just to come
in
so black would have to play a move like
this and then you can even consider
moves like d6
sometimes maybe not immediately because
of here here and probably the pawn's too
weak
um you can consider ideas like b4 which
not only tries to do this but puts the
bishop back and then
tries to get the queen in so i would say
that c6 is just the type of move which i
find very dangerous
so it takes takes the rook comes over uh
this is also a very logical way of
playing and i guess white's trying to
use the d5
square as well so a very tense uh
battle but i feel like white even though
they started off on the back foot by the
tempo loss in the opening is really
outplaying black a little here
this knight h4 move i also don't care
for and the main reason is because it
doesn't really do that much and it's out
of the game and i feel like
if white consolidates so b3 is a very
slow move although it's probably not bad
but i much prefer trying to play rook d5
and then trying to activate the queen
and i feel like if you achieve all that
it's just going to be bad business so
black's playing g4 trying to get counter
play this is understandable
but this can also seriously backfire
because keep in mind your own king is
quite weak so if i play something like
rook d5 here
even if we trade these pawns my own king
is open but after i play here
you might find that the black king on g8
is actually even worse
um so i'm not exactly sure what's
happening but i would say that like
black's king is likely to be just as
weak
but i definitely understand this
approach although it's definitely part
of why
in this position i definitely prefer
playing rook here because i feel like
that just cuts off all of black's ideas
and
white probably is going to be pretty
dominant in a position like that after
b3
g4 let us see
um so rook d5 played as kind of
predicted
if i played as kind of sorry i just
realized i didn't actually have the
the youtube chat open
uh so yeah guys i'm doing uh so i just
opened the chat hey everyone
uh for some reason i i forgot that i was
on on youtube there's a chat so uh
that's uh my that but anyway uh i think
this is a closed event so i don't
believe that there's access to the
tournament uh as far as challenging me
goes today i'm doing commentary for this
event but you'll definitely have other
attempts to do that
hey davina um
in any case uh so yeah king h1 rook g1 i
think is coming and again i think the
black king is gonna find it's a little
bit weaker like in this position i think
white house
black has to be very careful already
maybe something like some defensive
posture like this and then maybe trying
to double rooks uh the problem is that
even there you're not secure because
after this queen d3 rook here the king
here is not safe either
but i think that b5 is just too slow and
then king h1
uh is going to be just really really
nice
followed by rook check and i think that
black's own king is just going to be way
too weak for this position
yep king h1 played
yeah so feel free to follow along and
definitely ask me questions i am taking
out the youtube chat now for some reason
i didn't have it open a
bit of a brain meltdown but you know
these things happen
so yeah i think that rook g1 is going to
be really really strong here
so probably black has to try something
like rookie 6 to g6
uh but i i don't believe it should hold
uh but i think it's the only attempt now
because if you allow rook g1 check
by itself i think it's just going to be
too powerful i am not drinking beer i'm
drinking iced tea
uh but between this commentary the one i
did earlier and then another show i'm
doing
and then a two-hour lesson with a gm
of all things uh at the end of the day
there's definitely a beer in my future
so i'm looking forward to that but for
now it's just iced tea
um in any case i think rook g1 is going
to be very strong and actually in this
position this is an example of playing
too fast rookie one check probably is
just
good to have because if you play this
then a check you can't block with the
knight and if rook king here you can
maybe check anyway and if king here
then you can take back if you want
and it's probably a little bit better
because after this you do allow rookie
six which was played in the game
so this was an example where i actually
think that taking a moment to not just
recapture would have been a really
strong idea
uh because now at least rook g6 and
there's at least blacks fighting and
defending
so good resiliency by black here i would
say definitely not budweiser
not happening it'll probably be a
belgian beer
that's very strong and very tasty but
that's not until like
way later so rook takes g6 and rp7
looks pretty good uh but still actually
not so simple there's always this check
in the air and i'd say that
white zone king is never perfect so
it's one of those things where if black
hadn't achieved this amazing thing in
the opening by getting the pawn to e3
black would just be hosed here
but because black has the structure kind
of holding white at bay
um there's at least at least something
um i have to say though i
i'm still not exactly sure uh what
what's going on maybe the best is
actually to take
and then even withdraw the rook with the
idea of playing rook g1 because rook g1
is just going to be so nasty
white goes with something else entirely
this is a very counterintuitive move to
me because the bishop was so beautiful
on the long diagonal
um but i'm assuming the idea is you want
to basically make this knight feel
uncomfortable about its life
which seems kind of rude honestly but it
makes sense right because this knight is
a little bit annoying but in general i
definitely prefer to take the
rook on g6 and maybe we'll treat with
the rook and and try to target black's
king
uh keep in mind the bishop on c3 is just
quite good
so king takes g1 um
yeah so here it's kind of difficult to
suggest great moves he just goes back
which probably makes sense
um so the question is can white just
regroup and play bishop here queen here
i would say so uh moves like queen d3
immediately are also quite dangerous
with the idea of playing rook d6 i kind
of like that actually because
i like creating threats whenever i can
right immediate threats and this
creates the threat of rook d6 which
definitely looks pretty hard to parry
right like it's just a really strong
idea
um
so
what else we got here
[Music]
so what do we have knight back king h1
okay
so white just gets the king off the g
file this is also reasonable
but it does give black a move to maybe
activate the rook that's maybe the one
drawback to playing this way
um so rook d4
again this feels rather defensive right
like you could play queen d3 hitting
this knight and i think that that would
be probably a little bit better
yeah queen d3 i really like um with the
idea of rookie six i actually don't know
the average age of the competition uh
you'll have to ask
uh the club probably has that
information but i definitely i'm not
fully aware but yeah rook d4
queen c5 yeah again just passive moves
in general i just don't like in
positions like this i feel like you want
to play actively and go after black's
king
um yeah so this is this is a bit too
defensive for my taste the rook kind of
controls the knight but i feel like
you're not also
hitting black's king so i definitely
think that black is totally back in this
game if they
are on the ball here so for black i'd be
looking to activate my own forces so
something like rook b8 with ideas of
rook b1
queen f5 is a nice move because you hit
the rook and you also
guard the knight hitting the rook is not
so important it's more that just you
secure your position
so now for example ideas like bringing
the rook to the back rank are actually
potentially nasty
um
so queen g2 so now black actually has to
be careful because
sometimes their ideas like rook takes f4
and queen takes knight i don't know
yeah i think it works now actually so
you already have to be careful of this
so maybe a move like king h7 just
getting off the g file is good
the problem white would have though is
that yeah king f7 is also possible and
the problem is this queen on g2 is
actually just really bad now it's very
passive
so black gets a rook into the game again
the tables can turn in a position like
this very quickly
but notice how before i think white was
doing well with the queen here with the
rook coming into the seventh with the
rook on the
on the this file with the bishop here
but notice how a few passive moves can
kind of change the evaluation of the
position because now
i would say at the very least it's an
unclear position and a lot of this is
largely due to the fact that white's
pieces are more passive now
um so yeah i don't know if bishop b4
really threatens that much uh for white
i saw that suggestion somewhere so black
actually just totally ignores white
uh but this queen h3 because you're
hitting two things you're threatening
mate in one and also takes an f3 it's
definitely a nasty type of move
you do allow this check but this check
may not do that much maybe you just go
back to g8 and claim that these two
threats are greater
which may not be incorrect i suppose
white can play a move like this but then
because you can't take this pawn because
of the hanging rook on c8 but
it still looks a little bit flimsy to me
so
yeah this is already very very dangerous
i'd say for white
uh it's weird because black's king's so
open but because the pieces are more
passive now it's very difficult
also hello maria
[Music]
and let me see
hmm
so queen e2 so white decides to just
guard against both threats but again
with the queen on a more passive square
it enables black to kind of activate
um the question is how do you take
advantage of this right it's maybe not
so simple because your own king is kind
of in the open that's why i kind of
wanted to keep it here
so black decides to try to trade rooks
um
so i think the rook trade probably is
decent for black because i feel like
this queen with the weakness on f3 and
the back
rank could be pretty annoying so white
could definitely consider avoiding it
but
it's it's also that could also be
dangerous like you have to be very
careful
so this is b7 so yeah queen b7 check was
definitely possible but after king g8
the
white king is definitely weak right so
you have to be careful yeah here
i'm assuming rook d4 maybe is actually a
decent idea because i feel like with the
rooks on the board it's gonna be harder
for black to
do a lot he goes for it this makes sense
because now ideas like knight e5 are
always running into rook takes f4 so it
makes it harder for black to do anything
and i think it's very important that
black white as soon as they can start
pushing this pawn because first of all
it gives options for queen c4 um and
ideas like that
uh but also it just creates counterplay
so 95 allowing rook to except for
maybe it's a blunder it doesn't look
like you should allow this though
i'm guessing he missed that this pawn
was hanging with check in addition
so this definitely looks like something
that went wrong
so probably the king has to go this way
and then i like very much
maybe a move like rookie for just
pinning them tonight
and then you target the epon i think
this was a bad blunder
by white here
so we'll see
so the king goes to g7 yeah i mean
lots of options pinning the knight is
definitely very logical with the bishop
as well
um i definitely like this approach
hoping for qui-tex e3 uh maybe i don't
know the thing with queen xe3 is that
even there it's not so clear right
but yeah i think it's wise not to try to
take that pawn
i really like this bishop c3 move just
pinning the knight i think it makes a
lot of sense
um well there's a knight there's a
there's a rook covering the f3 pawn
so it's going to be harder as far as uh
well queen check king here i assume you
mean queen d5 but i i think the king was
just running like i don't think uh
you were actually helping your position
all that much because there was still
going to be a threat of this
so anyway but this looks quite good for
white i would say that black's probably
lost here
um because now the open king is just
really going to hurt you as well and and
i think that after a move like this
you're going to just be pinned up and
it's very hard to create threats for
yourself that's the problem like the
back ranks the only time
you could do it but let's say for
example even if you get in this
if i take a knight and then just block
with my bishop i still think you don't
have anything
um so king g8 was played and yeah i mean
obviously you could trade queens and
the end game's probably decent but you i
still have this e pawn so a move like
rookie four might be
a bit wiser just pinning the knight
first
white takes which maybe is okay but it
would not be my first choice i mean to
give up this beautiful bishop for a
knight that's just pinned to death
um i i would say that when people are up
material because because
people are taught to simplify so much
this is a huge pet peeve of mine
i'll probably mention it many times
which is that they just want to trade
off everything they're like oh i'm up a
pawn i want to trade
but the fact is that you don't want to
trade your great pieces for your
opponents which are
in trouble and this knight is such a
problematic piece for black because you
can just pin it to death
so i hate trading off pieces that are in
trouble and doing things like this i
feel like you're you're doing a service
to your opponent
so i understand that white's trading and
is going to claim that they're up upon
but i feel like
if you trade off your opponent's worst
pieces especially a queen end game like
this with the black white king so
passive this pawn potentially dangerous
i feel like this is a good way to ask
for trouble and to make the win
uh way harder and in fact now i would
say the position is just unclear
because again this this king is just so
much worse black's king is nice and open
so this is the c4 square so i don't know
what you're talking about but
but yeah i would say that in general
though you should not take nights like
this when you have your opponent pinned
up
uh it's really tough and yeah i would
agree with that uh saying it was like
now all of a sudden it actually is risky
like i could easily see black winning
this game which i think that if you had
left the knight pinned would be almost
impossible
yeah but i really really dislike this
approach so queen d1 though looks like a
nice move because now you at least have
this check
and you're still guarding the key entry
squares for black
um but even here even if you get in
queen d6 i would say it's not so clear
ah so now you have a queen trade you
have to calculate so if here
takes takes takes king here oops
king here king here king here king here
uh pawn uh you also had e2
and then takes at the very least black's
not worse let me tell you that
uh but okay you always have to calculate
it so yeah probably queen d3 makes sense
so now you're trying to go after this
pawn
um but it's still outrageously
complicated even moves like
queen here are possible with the idea
that if you take the pawn
i check and i at least have a perpetual
probably i have to take the perpetual
but queen f6 actually is an interesting
option in a position like that
uh well i don't think it's an easy win
if you trade off on d6 uh smart because
you lose one of your pawns back
and in this position it's definitely not
easy to trade queen so i don't know if i
quite agree with that um but i think
that whites may be on top again because
this king is now better when the king
was back here it was really
a kind of a poor situation for the king
this is still really difficult to ever
win like i'm not so sure you can
actually win this
but i would say that your chances are a
little bit better yeah here even if you
just start pushing this pawn i'd say
that it's very very difficult
for white to actually win a position
like this um because the king is so open
because these pawns are weak i actually
don't even like the movie e5 i think
that you should actually try to advance
your king maybe
try to like put your queen on a better
square but honestly these queen endings
are so difficult to win
um that i would suspect a draw is
actually reasonably likely in this
position
yeah i don't know i mean you can
definitely push the pawn for black but i
also think that checking is kind of
annoying because
the white king doesn't have like obvious
shelter i guess
here you're gonna play to h4 and then
you run out of chex
uh which is one of the reasons why i
don't like just checking mindlessly yeah
i don't know why he's not going to h4
going to h4 makes sense i guess you have
to watch out for queen check
take take take a5 oh is that the problem
wow that would be quite annoying
wow ah so they end up drawing okay so
really close game guys really
interesting game
um and it's a swiss event so
you have uh you're not going to have a
bunch of games all going at once it's
not going to be like a
an arena event where you have a side so
let's see what we have here so this is
uh it looks like chess logic against
sandro is
chess logic is simply winning here
um yeah so he's gonna take this rook
yeah that's over
uh what else have we got
um
is this the game yeah this is with f5
checks sorry
some reason lee chess is not loading
very well for me i'm seeing like old
positions and stuff
okay so what else have we got let me
refresh this
okay so we have one game left and that
is this one yeah this is a winning end
game
uh if you move the pawns over you can't
win because you
end up stalemating but because the king
has this h
file this is not a stalemate position
which means the king can move
and here you just have to not queen you
can either play here in queen or you
could knight if you want to be super
fancy about it
here it takes i mean it's hard to give a
rating based on one game
uh i would say that game like it looked
like between
two very reasonable players i would say
like it was definitely a tough game
uh but i can't assign an exact rating
it's impossible off of one game
at least for me like you have to see
many many games to do that because
everyone has variants right especially
young and improving players so
there are some games i'll have students
where they look like you know say
they're rated like
1600 they'll be games where they look
like they're 2100 and then games where
they look like they're 1200
so you can't really go by one game
but i would say that game looked like a
pretty well played game just i think
that
white got a bad opening then outplayed
their opponent but then played
a little bit too passively so it looks
like that's over for this round
so there's gonna be a 30 second break
and then the next round will start so as
we saw
uh jenna's 2007 chess
logic jay josh gotta root for him
obviously
007 uh aaron sunboy and
hockey0430 all one
uh prose man hyper also i think that was
the buy i want to say
uh and then there was a draw between st
louis n7 and casual
player the game we went over
uh so let us see uh which game so we
want to go over say one of the people
leading uh let's check out this game
um jenna's 2007 versus hockey 0430.
um so in this one
looks like a pretty symmetrical position
so far yeah i mean you get a lot of
these games a lot from these kind of
these sort of hybrid systems where both
sides are kind of copying each other a
little bit
but what i find about these symmetrical
positions is that they're
much harder to play than they look uh
now personally as black i prefer to be
castled and have the option of knight
c6 which maybe puts more pressure on the
center in certain situations
although the knight on d7 is not bad
just as an example but i would say that
there's lots of nuance
it's often who gets an ite 5 or e4 first
who initiates play somewhere who commits
a queen side weakness something like
that
uh yeah they're definitely young so i
think middle school like they said
middle school
to high school something like this so a
fairly
large age range as far as how to improve
the game i mean for most people you have
to work on lots of tactics
so doing just tons of them
but i would say that that's a very
general answer like everyone
has their own thing to they have to do
uh but i would say definitely looking
like playing slower time control games
looking over those games seriously
uh doing lots of tactics lots of puzzles
and just getting
in a good amount of play as well um
so there are there are so many things
you can do to improve right like you
could ask anyone they'll kind of tell
you the same things and honestly
there's no special answer like that's
just the stuff you have to do
so yeah so here as i mentioned because
in this structure it's who establishes
their knight
so white's established the knight here
this is the typical for stonewall setups
now i would say that establishing a
knight here doesn't mean that you're
just crushing or even that you have an
advantage
but it does make your position easier to
play you have a bit more space you have
a clear plan that you can maybe play for
an attack
either bringing the rook over maybe
bringing the queen over
and that black has to deal with your
attack you have a clear plan and the
problem black can have in a position
like this
is that oftentimes you don't have a
clear plan and it makes it so that your
life's more difficult
but you still have to be cautious for
example after these moves you have to
make sure you've calculated the move c4
so white does go for the attack but now
the move c4 might actually prove
annoying with the idea that on pawn
takes pawn takes
you probably have to sack the exchange
which is at least interesting but it's
definitely not clear
um and of course you don't want to move
back and allow to move c3
um so i would say white doesn't really
want to give up this knight like
unless you're checkmating with an id
like this like white wants to keep this
night this night's really annoying for
black so moving that night i wouldn't
really recommend
um as far as openings go i would say
that
um i personally like at least sticking
with a particular set of openings a
little bit
i i don't like playing just one system
forever i think that's a common mistake
and then people don't become very
versatile
so i think you definitely have to want
to mix it up a little bit but i would
say that
a lot of players do the opposite where
they basically just learn every
open they try to play everything and
then they don't really learn anything
deeply themselves
uh like they kind of can play everything
but they don't
really know anything and they also
tend to study at openings all the time
which i think is not really great for
most players because you still have to
learn how to play the rest of the game
so i think you want to strike a balance
you want to have a little bit of variety
but you want to give yourself time to
get it
so uh let us see what's happening now
yeah so black you can see that black
actually has difficult decisions to make
i think in this position
a6 is just way too slow of a move uh
because it's understandable you want to
get your pawns going but you don't have
that much time
and now that this attack is kind of
coming in you have to be very careful so
i think this was the moment to really
seriously consider c4 trying to break up
black's position
i'm not saying this exchange stack type
position is so clear like takes takes i
think that white might have a lot of
compensation
but i also think that like black had to
try something like this because
you could also think about putting a
knight on e4 i don't think that's stupid
either
if you decided the exchange sack wasn't
to your liking or grabbing the exchange
wasn't to your legging
so to answer your question rohit
um i would say in this position again
taking here
it opens up your bishop but i'd say you
only do it if you're going to win by
force because
when you allow this if you allow d4
opening up my bishop all of a sudden the
tables are turning on you
so you have to be very careful about
making this capture i would say you
don't want to do it unless you have a
forced continuation
but i think what white's going for very
smartly is they're targeting this pawn
instead so if you have to play h6 then
g4 g5 is probably gonna wreck you if you
play g6 then your ideas of taking on c5
someday might be good with this open
bishop maybe not immediately
but probably black has to try something
like this black ended up going here
and now bishop takes h7 was played and
now it's going to be
very very uh difficult although i think
there are some mistakes being made here
so in this position
after takes takes maybe you should be
taking this first
with the idea that on the recapture with
either piece you play queen h5 and then
this knight can't move due to mate
so you're basically going to just take
the knight next and of course there's no
mate right
but it looks really really devastating
moves like rook takes h7 also could be
considered with the idea that on queen
takes
king takes you go here you take
obviously you have at least a draw maybe
you only have a draw there in which case
you probably should go for more
uh but these are like this position i
would give you this is an example of a
position where i would spend a good
amount of time as white because you're
about to like take and crash through and
maybe win
so if you spend a couple extra minutes
and play it accurately
i think that it's going to be really
important
so whether you take here first whether
you take here first
whether you go for one of these sacks
like it's such an important moment that
you want to spend that time to make sure
you get it right because this
i'm not so sure about because now knight
f6 and i'm guessing they missed this
that not only are you defending the
knight you're defending this pawn as
well i'm guessing that white banked on
the fact that this is a double attack
but this move is also a double defense i
guess you could call it
doing this and then defending and now
all of a sudden it's not so clear yes
you still have an attack but you're also
down a piece
and being down a piece doesn't make your
life any easier
but i would still say that you have a
very strong attacking potential here and
it's a very dangerous position
for the black pieces yeah i mean rook g3
is possible but then you're not putting
any pressure on here right so you don't
have any bishop takes h7 i think that
rook h3 is the right idea
i know this because i've seen so many
stonewalls
that i've seen this attack happen many
many many times
that it was the correct idea it just
wasn't executed well i think that
white should have taken a moment here to
figure out whether you take whether you
take
i think both those options are extremely
promising
taking is probably the safest though
taking d7 and then just queen out here
and i think that
you're just forcing your opponent to
pitch that knight and you're just gonna
be up a pawn with an attack so i think
that that's the safest route
um or the simplest i would say
queen here so yeah the knight on d2 can
try to get in the game but it still
takes time so black takes here
white takes back and black grabs a pawn
now sometimes grabbing a pawn actually
helps you defend because this queen
actually helps defend the knight a
little bit so maybe this move is
actually quite reasonable i would always
be nervous about
taking a pun like this but sometimes to
get counterplay you actually have to
grab these risky pawns and just say look
you at least have to prove something now
so i think that white should maybe
consider bringing this knight in which i
think was suggested by one of you
uh it definitely makes a lot of sense to
me
um i don't really see another course of
action that makes a lot of sense you
could try g4 g5 trying to put pressure
on the knight this way
um and i don't know i mean it looks like
a very difficult situation for black
because
it's really hard to the thing is with
these knights that
they're they're kind of sturdy but
they're also like
you can't move anything like you can't
try to move you can't ever move this
knight because you get mated
you can't move this night because this
guy's gonna hang in most cases now with
the queen here maybe you have an
opportunity but it's gonna be difficult
um and i just say that in general
this makes life kind of difficult for
you you know
um so i don't know i
i would say that these these nights make
your life hard uh so even though white's
maybe played this inaccurately i still
think their attack is very dangerous
uh but i definitely like yeah so
retreating i don't know i mean i
definitely like bringing this knight
into the game
his idea though i think is he wants to
take this uh while he has the chance
the problem might be a move like bishop
e7 trying to guard against that
because notice how if you take here and
i take the queen still guards that's why
this the beauty of this pawn grab
was that you actually guard against this
but maybe bishop here you could even
think about e4 with the idea of taking
this knight then
cutting off the queen so plenty and
plenty of
plenty of options
um
so bishop c5
maybe i mean like the main thing though
is you want to crack at these pieces
right so he plays bishop here
immediately so it takes takes and i'm
assuming
so queen h4 so the idea queen h6r the
idea of this is to throw in this check
and this looks like a very very powerful
idea indeed um
so i'm wondering how black defends
against this the problem is you are kind
of all in
um so queen g6 allows rook here and this
uh at the very least white wins the
piece back although the game is far from
over
one other option by the way here uh was
you could even try taking this
and then maybe putting your bishop here
just to interfere with the rook that's
sometimes a common way to try to defend
um and you're just relying on this
queen's defense
along this diagonal so uh definitely
plenty of options queen g6 gives back
the material
but also blacks made a lot of headway
and now you're really glad you took this
pawn
so knight g5 and i'm wondering if here
white played a little too hasty because
white just took this queen but
you also have the opportunity to bring
the queen back here
and maybe this actually makes sense as
well i guess you still have bishop takes
e3 i feel like white should not have
allowed any of this like allowing takes
takes on e3 is gonna be at least give
black some resources but i really would
want to keep the queens on i feel like
once you trade the queens
uh blacks all have good chances i guess
you could take like this and then take
the queen this way might be also
possible
but he goes for this and yeah i don't
know it feels like the two bishops here
are very very strong
i would definitely consider playing f5
to not allow all these pieces into the
game
uh you also have a pawn hanging here
which probably could be taken
um so i have the feeling actually that
like both sides forgot about this pawn
hanging
um because i think taking this pawn and
then playing a move like f5
something like this looks quite good to
me um i don't really see an issue with
this
uh takes here
takes bishop back takes rook d6 yeah i
mean it's still a very complicated
position
but uh i think materials even and the
two bishops are pretty good in positions
like this usually
uh but what black skin is also not so
clear i think if you had taken this pawn
though black would just be much better
uh here king up
so i don't know here i would definitely
consider also moves like 95 trying to
target this pawn
uh because if you force it up then you
can maybe bring the other knight in
maybe try h4
i i don't exactly have the inside track
on all this stuff
uh graham so i don't know i wouldn't ask
me about sing phil cup type questions
things like that uh definitely
the the club can probably answer these
questions far better than i can
so i don't know it's uh but i would say
that it would be cool if certain things
could happen but at the moment there's
it's just everything's up in the air
right um
so rook c1 rook c8 takes takes
knight e5 g5
so again it's it's kind of an unclear
end game so these guys are playing a
really interesting game
i feel like though the opening like
after the opening with the stonewall and
bishop h7 if white had played a little
bit more carefully they would have just
won
but black also had to be very
resourceful because even after the
blunder
it still was so dangerous and black
really found um
black really found a lot of resources
here so knight f3
so trying to target this g5 pawn makes a
lot of sense
defense now you might have thought about
um trying to defend this way first of
all you don't allow this but also you
don't allow you you don't allow yourself
to be pinned so for example after here
h4 you can simply take it
um but this also is is not unreasonable
so here black plays bishop f6
the thing is you'd love to play this
getting the rook in but you have to deal
with this fork
so the move bishop f6 makes a lot of
sense
here and now king h5 so you have to be
careful kings like this can get mated
sometimes but they also can be quite
decent
all right see i knew these guys would
have answers for you
so uh knight goes to f3
i don't know honestly here this is just
such a messy position
there's so much going on uh as black i'd
be really tempted to activate this rook
though so for example rook c6 to c2
would be something very tempting for me
uh whereas as white this rook looks very
awkward to me so i'd want to be able to
play like something like knight h7 or
knight f7
and bring the rook here and then if you
can start launching these pawns this
could be really really bad for black
so i actually think that this whole idea
of allowing white to take could be very
dangerous
but the question is what to do here like
this i think is coming
so black does go for this which looks
really reasonable
um but i would be very worried about
this type of thing uh so i guess maybe
here you can take
because the pin definitely looks very
flimsy though
i'd be very very worried here
yeah we got tracy on the ball with
information guys um
so yeah definitely feel free to
obviously ask me about the chest
position and stuff like that but as far
as information on the players and as far
as um
as far as information about club events
definitely i am not the one to ask but
definitely you can ask in the chat
because we do have tracy here
and we have uh the person manning the uh
manning the st louis chess club account
as well
so i'm sure they have all info
so yeah i don't know this is already
kind of weird like but definitely you
want to fix this rook right like to me
if this rook
was to become active white would just be
winning so
i'd be definitely tempted by moves like
this the question is can black get away
with taking
it looks so sketchy and maybe i'm just
missing something
so my idea ah no you can't because if
knight takes
okay if you check then king here then
you can't take as a mate which is really
hilarious
um so just to give you an idea after
here takes
takes so maybe you take back immediately
and then this isn't made because you
have this square
but it looks so sketchy like there has
to be something
maybe there isn't you know sometimes
there are these things that look
um look really messed up
but so 91
91 actually makes sense so you're you're
trying to cover the c2 square but then
you can also try to reroute your knight
in this way
um but i guess black can also try to
block you
uh from doing that so it moves like e5
and trying to put the bishop one five
uh could be quite nasty
um yep so black goes for it
so yeah if knight d3 you have moves like
bishop f5 you have bishop g4 you have
rook c2 check
so i feel like 91 is kind of a step in
the wrong direction
uh but again the main thing is just i
want to fix this rook this rook is just
blocking all of white's play
so really really interesting endgame
really interesting position
um so i'm kind of hesitant to switch
from it just because there's so much
going on here
um yeah again like i don't like
switching a lot in general when i do
commentary a lot of people do it
differently
um but especially if a game's
interesting i hate kind of switching
away from it so
uh i'm gonna stick to this for now but
obviously like there are plenty of
uh there are other games going um
yeah i'm kind of curious what happens
after e5 honestly like this pawn coming
up like if the pawn lands here even this
knight might just be dead
so it feels like white has to maybe move
that night but then you have to watch
out for check you have to watch out for
bishop here
i think this 91 move is maybe just not
not the best
so this knight went back interesting so
these knights all of a sudden look
kind of sad but at the same time
sometimes you can't take advantage so
here i very much like to move bishop g4
because it cuts off the rook
and it puts pressure on the knights like
the knight and then there's just there's
just no moves
black goes with e4 instead which is more
forceful and but the thing is i thought
that knight d4 was at least a move now
so you can't just take on h4 and just be
winning
but i feel like the move bishop g4 would
just be like so nasty because then
i'm threatening to take in some
positions i'm threatening e4 and you
just have no moves at all
so it just makes your life very
difficult
e4 knight d4
which is pretty forced because otherwise
the h4 pawn drops with the pin
so here probably you should not simplify
and trade
in general i think that that's probably
the wrong approach you want to keep your
two bishops which are so strong
so the only question is where you want
to go you can play a move like rook c1
you can play rook c3 the problem with
positions like this is often that you
have too many options
so rook c1 rook c3 are definitely high
on my list rook c7 is also quite
playable i think
um
yeah it's amazing how strong these
pieces are so it just
piece play matters so much white had
these knights here and if white had
tried to get the rook in and tried to
push the pawn i think that
it would have been quite promising but
as things are i think that black's
starting to take over the game
[Music]
definitely a lot of options here
black goes for rook c3 i like this move
um
targeting pawns stuff like that
yeah black's white truck is having
issues here yeah
um however uh maybe rook here now is is
a valid option
you give away the pawn with check but
then you play here then you bring the
knight in
oops knights don't move like that josh
so i don't know i think maybe rook here
like white has to get active though if
white stays passive i think the position
is just death
so i think that white has to play very
active actively here to try to have a
chance in this game
uh because again i think black should
have leaped at the chance to cut off the
rook
earlier rather than playing e4 too fast
so king e2 is played instead but now i
feel like you're walking into this move
and if king d2 you can simply retreat
with the rook also you're walking into
bishop takes c3 here
and in fact this probably just wins
because if rook g5 check you take that's
the key
and uh that's a lot hanging so it seems
like white fell apart a little bit i
would say that this move would have kept
white in the game for sure
um with the idea of g3 and then fixing
this knight you basically
every position i just want to fix pieces
is what you'll notice
but white played king e2 leaving the
rook undefended and i believe now it is
simply losing
uh if you go here i can simply move my
bishop back somewhere
if you play check i take and then your
rook still hangs
it's very important of course after
check you don't go back and then allow
takes
um so i think it's just losing though
we'll check back on this game but i
would say it looks lost so maybe yeah so
here let's just make sure he takes
yeah and then he takes here yeah it
should be winning so we can we can
check back on this to make sure the game
was won but let us maybe switch to
another game
[Music]
let's see so let's check out chess logic
okay so this game uh let's just do a
brief recap of what happened so this was
a king's indian
with bishop g5 by the way these systems
are not so easy to face they're one of
those where people underestimate them a
lot i think
so black goes for this so this is very
consistent to me so black played knight
a6 c5 which is one of the common
ideas but they did it in two moves they
played here and here
and giving costing yourself tempe tends
not to work whereas white's just playing
all very natural moves
probably this is unnecessary probably
you can just play rook d1 or even just
castles
[Music]
so it's probably overly safe but
definitely this position is
uh looking reasonably good for white now
but guys nothing too crazy yet so takes
takes
queen bishop out and then here he i
don't know some weird stuff yeah b5
though i think is too much
i i would say that pawns like this
actually tend to be underestimated
uh people see a sp pawn structure like
this and they think of it as crippled
but the fact is these pawns run together
really well
and they control lots of squares and
they're not weak like you'll notice
after a4 these pawns are just so nasty
because
they're um they just stay together and
they're impossible to attack so this
kind of structure i would say
is easily underestimated in my
experience
so i would definitely not sacrifice a
pawn in order to give white that
structure i would say that it's your
passive here it's a difficult position
but you'll probably have to play it
patient and try to trade pieces so for
example moves like 94 come to my mind
trying to be active trying to open up
the bishop and trying to swap some
pieces so that your
white's extra space is not quite as
significant
[Music]
so black does blockade the square which
is quite nice
but i would say that these pawns that's
a pretty clear extra pawn so i would be
very happy to be white here
[Music]
so black tries to get counter play which
i can appreciate
uh the problem is that i don't know if
you're actually gonna get there and now
the night's really passive probably here
you could at least think about taking
and trying to activate the knight
uh i'm also not sure retreating was the
wisest course of action
although it's kind of understandable i
guess
um but yeah this looks actually just
very painful because i think that
these pawns are just so solid you can
see it right and
they make black's life really miserable
you can even put a rook here and things
just start to get really nasty
um so he played h3
queen there um yeah i mean position
there are lots of options here honestly
like the idea of putting the rook here
and doubling looks just so
i would hate to be uh black here it's
just such a difficult position to play
but it's why you don't allow this
so queen e3 was played instead in the 98
but this is
obviously also yeah rook 766
and now i think it's really a matter of
technique for white uh how they convert
it so obviously you don't want to give
up this pawn so doubling rooks would be
a little too hasty but you have so many
options here
um i definitely like the idea of maybe
solidifying this pawn somehow
um even a move like queen b3 so that you
can maybe bring this knight in that you
can maybe start pushing
even pushing this pawn i don't think is
too too hasty because this bishop
controls this pawn so nicely
so even just starting to push your pawns
looks pretty good
but i would say that this is just a
really tough position for black to play
yeah i'm kind of curious what white
chooses because we're getting to the
point in the game where neither of them
have tons of time and keep in mind this
is no increment at all
uh and i understand why they do this uh
because it's obviously easier to predict
when the rounds end and otherwise
without increment it can
go forever but the fact is that uh with
no increment it gets kind of dicey
around the end of the game so you end up
with under a minute you're
really blitzing it out so even if you
play lots of bullet
it's uh you can get kind of rough around
the edge of the game
so while i'd say neither side is in
danger of flagging just yet it's still
very difficult so white goes with a5
which is an approach i don't mind at all
um sometimes if you're in doubt about
what you should
how you should approach a position and
you're looking for a solid move but
nothing comes to mind sometimes
just pushing your pawns is good just
don't overthink it
because a lot of the times you just push
your extra puns and they become
dangerous right
so someone mentions bishop before i
definitely think this is a reasonable
try trying to at least target this pawn
uh so then here maybe queen comes out
here to try to defend he goes with
bishop c4 which is also a move
um but yeah as i was saying sometimes
you just want to push your pawns
because there are times when you want to
be more fancy there are times when you
want to be like okay i want to be super
precise not allow counterplay do all of
that
but a lot of the times the the way to do
that is you simply push those guys
and it just becomes really uh annoying
to deal with
so black tries to little harassment
trying to take that pawn
uh oh so they allow him to take i don't
know if you're supposed to do that
although it still looks very nasty
because you can actually take and then
take here at the end
um which looks pretty good because that
b pawn is going to be very strong
and if queen c1 check you can always
play knight f1 and that's actually
fairly solid
so even though you're technically losing
a pawn probably because this guy hangs i
think this b-pawn just ends up queening
so probably this was not necessary but
we're coming to the end of the game now
where things are really really heating
up
um so really really exciting
black just resigns okay oh they hung a
queen
oh they expected they thought this was
the only legal move so they pre-moved
oh nasty but to be fair
after night here i guess night here
though it's still not over but oh
you can take this pawn and guard against
the threat
yeah probably still winning so let's see
so there's one game left
and uh oh man oh man poor white they're
down to four seconds and they're down to
rook i think this is over
oh man they even let him take
that's still two bishops and lots of
pawns so as long as black doesn't uh
mess this one up i think it's gonna be
over yeah you have many ways to go about
it
the white's not flagging this is
impressive play ah but now you queen
yeah so that should end it um
all right so then the next round so it
the leader is currently chest logic j
josh go josh and uh
and uh hakio four three oh uh i'm to
take a very quick bathroom break before
the next round i'll be back
in a second
all right let us see
so um
in the midst of round three now let me
try to find an interesting one so
currently hockey and chess logic are in
the lead so why don't we check out their
game
because they're currently leading um
so e4 c6 we have a caro
yeah bishop b6 here is a little bit
unusual most people um
play either knight c6 or here i'm
wondering if they got confused because
there's a line that goes knight c6
bishop g5 and then bishop e6
but playing bishop e6 here feels quite
artificial
um to me like the bishop here just
doesn't really belong
against bishop g5 in particular it makes
sense because often after takes you can
actually justify the bishop here
even though it's a little bit weird but
i would say that in this particular
position
it's definitely a little bit odd looking
to me maybe it's a move and i'm just
unaware of it but
for example moves like queen b3 come to
mind trying to sort of punish this and
target this pawn um definitely come to
mind
but white decides just to take and play
here which maybe is all
right fi also here you should be two so
this is a little bit again
you're kind of not punishing your
opponents i mean i would at least
consider bishop b5 check
trying and maybe knight e5 or moves like
knight g5 in some positions like
sometimes
your opponent plays a move like this and
it's if you give them enough time it
just becomes a fine normal move so
sometimes you have to think about
punishing them a little bit earlier
so i would definitely kind of consider
ideas like that for sure
so here in fact white does play queen b3
and now it's it's definitely a large
think
uh playing it here was an interesting
choice though because it feels like
black's ready to castle now which is not
ideal for taking this pawn so i
definitely don't agree with white's
choice of kind of
simple move and then trying to take
advantage i think queen b3 earlier um
when black was less developed who could
have been more potent
playing it here of course is possible so
now there are lots of options black can
definitely take this knight i don't see
any reason not to because if you try to
take this pawn i can play bishop
d5 hitting your queen defending my rook
and then i can move my knight next
so that would be actually just a blunder
so after a knight takes knight you have
to take with a queen which
to my mind doesn't look all that natural
so
black plays knight b6 instead which is
also reasonable looking i suppose
uh the queen can move back and then
castle's 96 so i feel like
black really got led off the hook here
because black's position is totally
normal now
but i think that if white had played a
little bit more punishing they could
have
made this move feel a little awkward
um because as it is now it seems like
black's just doing fine you can play
knight c6 hit this pawn
give it castle and you can claim that
the bishop on e6 makes sense because
you're maybe supporting knight c4 ideas
you're supporting bishop c4 ideas
it's almost like a reverse tarash
actually
where black has the white white in this
case white has the iqp
and uh black has the fee and shadow
bishop is trying to play for the c4
square the d5 square
uh so very much like a reverse tarash
and because white's lost time with the
queen
it may even be almost a transposition
because you're not even down a tempo for
this really
um normally there's actually a line that
goes like this in the tarash
but i suspect the knight on b6 may even
be better
so i don't know i think knight c knight
c6 bishop e3 and then maybe a move like
knight c4
uh and i think already black's even
playing for a slight advantage although
objectively it probably should be still
somewhat close to equal i want to say
ah you have to be careful after here
yeah so after here bishop e3 if you try
knight c4 maybe d5 is an issue
although even there there's takes takes
takes and life becomes crazy
takes probably you shouldn't allow this
i don't know
looks a little nuts but maybe it's
playable
but you don't have to do this either
after here you can play like this night
here is a perfectly fine move you can
play bishop here trying to trade off the
bishop instead you can even just play a
move like rook c8 just developing a
piece and saying okay what exactly are
you doing with your life
um and i think that's a very valid
question actually so even a move like
rook c8 i just kind of like
i feel like it's just a useful move and
there's nothing really to indicate that
black should really be worried about
life um
but yeah i mean you have knight d5 you
have bishop c4 you have rook c8 you have
so many nice moves the key is actually
to
kind of find one you like and then pick
it and not overthink the situation too
much but knight c4 if you want to play
knight c4 you have to make sure d5 is
not a good move that's the one
caveat that if you try to play knight c4
you have to have it calculated out in my
case i
i don't really like it i think that it's
unnecessary to allow this
um i don't know i do kind of like
trading these bishops strategically but
i would also worry about some d5 moves
so i don't know moves like rook c8 are
it's kind of hard to go wrong with them
uh moves like knight d5 like they're
just so solid
um but of course the position is still
relatively normal you're just playing an
iqp nothing nothing tragic has happened
really
um but again i think the key is
especially in shorter time controls and
i'm still
including rapid and shorter time which
don't overthink it
you just kind of want to play your moves
play salt nice and solid don't
allow anything too crazy
and that's kind of the the main deal
with that
so let us see
black still has yet to make a decision
i could take a brief look i'll get back
to this i'm kind of curious if there's
anything going on in the other games
uh it's worth noting
so the other one jay josh my boy
is and like me he's a fan of e4 e5
i have to root for my namesake obviously
sorry for my less than
unbiased commentary he even plays my
line he plays knight f6 i've always been
a fan of knight
six more than bishop c5 even though i
have played both for sure
so d3 bishop c5 knight c3
yeah so this is kind of a typical so
again i kind of like putting the bishop
on e7 or even h6 systems are kind of
interesting but bishop c5 of course is
fine
yeah this is stuff you see again at
scholastic level you see this all the
time
but then when you get to you know master
higher master levels and gm level
you almost never see it this kind of
position because people kind of know how
to deal with it as black it's not
um it's not quite as potent
so h3 yeah i mean this is kind of common
a lot of people play bishop here and
then there's h6 g5 type stuff
i actually saw a game in the first
scholastic tournament today which i did
commentary on that
after bishop g5 there was a really
exciting game with here here
g5 and then the knight sack which is a
bit dubious i think
and black actually won a really really
cool game uh
very fast but this is so this is
something i would say is dangerous like
in this kind of position often you want
to play h6 or some move like that just
so you don't allow this kind of thing
if you play castles and bishop g5 now at
the very least this is just annoying
like maybe it's no big deal maybe you're
okay here but when you have this pin
it's just really kind of nasty and a
move like a6 i think is just too slow
and now you have to contend with moves
like knight d5 all the time
um so black goes for this and now i
guess you have to consider taking
so the main issue with taking is that
you do allow knight takes d5 but these
are lines you have to calculate
and calculate them well i would say
because these lines because
obviously if knight takes takes takes
you're just winning right
because the pin is too powerful but
after knight takes the idea is usually
um sorry you want to do this but now
even here you have to
contend with moves like queen h5 for
instance and maybe there's queen f6
uh or something weird like that actually
i don't know that's actually kind of
sketchy
but you know you have to contend with
queen h5 with the idea that on pawn
takes bishop takes and your king is kind
of weak
um so i don't know i would actually be i
mean this is a serious move to consider
and i believe that
maybe i don't know how long chess man
thought here but i would say that this
was kind of a crucial position
so knight takes g5 should definitely be
considered bishop back to g3 instead was
played takes takes
king up this is a common move by the way
in these kind of positions you want to
sometimes play this or even f6 just to
solidify get out of this pin
um so very very common idea
but you're noticing how a slow move like
a6 is really felt in a position this
sharp right
when the position is this sharp you got
to play fast you have to be
very precise and not play any slow moves
usually
so this game is also quite sharp um
so yeah this is these are the two games
we have to keep an eye on because this
one
definitely could heat up but uh at the
moment josh is thinking
so let's see what happened in this game
oh f5 is played so we'll definitely have
to keep an eye on that game that game
looks like it's going to be very
exciting
but okay so we have this position bishop
g4 was chosen this move i don't like and
the main reason is because i feel like
if you try to grab this pawn first of
all this is a clear tempo loss right
because you have bishop e6 bishop
uh g4 and i think that the bishop on e6
makes a lot of sense with this d5 square
and also you're allowing all sorts of
stuff like here after h3
it's one thing uh sometimes you're
allowing d5 and then after takes bishop
takes again
you're just kind of losing time a little
bit
um but h3 and the idea is that after
takes takes it looks like you're
blundering a pawn but because this
always hangs that's not the case
and again you're you're kind of giving
up the two bishops and allowing the
position to be opened
which also is in general something i
would not be a fan of
so i can't say i like this bishop g4
approach uh by chess logic i think that
they should have tried one of the moves
i mentioned either just rook c8 bishop
c4 maybe knight d5
um all of this
so definitely something i would mention
so let me go back to this game because i
think that this is just going to be a
much more exciting game from what i've
seen
so c3 so black does play f5 and this
queen d2 move i'm not a fan of because
you're allowing f4
uh usually in these situations after f5
it's automatic move to just take this
pawn now
you don't want to play it just on pure
autopilot because there are times when
you can't do this
but i think here in particular you
should absolutely take this pawn because
then if
bishop takes you have all sorts of ways
to try to play you can try to castle
king's side and then just
sort of maneuver your knight around you
can try to castle queen side and then
just try to open up the king which is
very open already
um you can try to have castle and even
d4
after you've got your king out of the
center try to play d4 and open up the
position that way
you have so many possibilities but i
would say allowing f4 is almost always a
no-no because
you end up with a bishop shot out of the
game and it makes my king safer
i don't necessarily have to win anything
i just have to keep your bishop out of
the game and with like safe king it
should be really really nasty
and it means that you canceling kingside
is almost always impossible
so i really dislike allowing the move f4
but it wasn't played so i'm wondering if
i'm just blundering something or if
these guys just have a different view of
the position than i do somehow
but yeah f4 is definitely in the air for
me i don't have to win the bishop to
want to play f4
uh it makes my king safer it shuts down
the white bishop
uh i don't know where you mean b1 and
then get the seventh rank
uh exactly oh you mean in the previous
game i see
yeah that's maybe possible so an 87
yeah i guess i guess after 97 you can't
stop f4 anyway so maybe this makes sense
but you do allow moves like d4 which i
think at least make the game a little
bit
messier but maybe it's not a big deal
so instead the bishop goes back and now
f4 is played so
black does indeed go for it and here i
think that uh
josh i'm assuming it's a josh i'm hoping
it's josh
has a pretty good position here
um so you have to be a little cautious
obviously the move d4 is still kind of
nasty if you have to take but i don't
think you ever do i think you can play
knight g6
if d4 you can simply retreat because i
don't think the trades are going to be
helpful
at some point you could think about
queen f6 and maybe h4 h5 g4 trying to
even restrict things further
but i would say the important thing in a
position like this is you don't have to
rush for that you want to keep the game
under control because with a bishop like
this
as long as you don't allow your opponent
too much counter play you should
probably just be close to winning
um so i think that the important thing
for black is to kind of keep things sort
of solid but i think for white allowing
f4
is a really big mistake and not
something i think they should do
black plays for a5 a4 which is a very
typical idea but once again i do not
like allowing d4 because i feel like
when these pawns get broken up and then
white tries to go here this bishop might
see the light of day you know
and one of the most important things
when you do shut your opponent's bishop
out is do not let it see the light of
day
so i don't like allowing d4 when this
pawn is a little bit looser
and the idea is that a pawn takes you
don't have to take with the pawn and
allow bishop b4 of course you can play
tier takes i don't take with the knight
and there's still the idea of h4
maybe it's no big deal but i would much
prefer to not do that
uh white just plays a4 though it's very
respectful of this a4 push
uh this is not an open tournament manage
this is a closed tournament
um so
uh let me see so bishop d7 played again
i don't like
ignoring this move for black i think
that you should
constantly kind of be aware of it and
maybe just solidify your position like
this to make sure that d4 you can keep
things closed
again as long as you keep the position
under control this bishop is just
just really terrible
so bishop d7
yeah really heat that's that's a
possible idea that after takes takes you
can even think about f3 and getting the
bishop out this way
but that's kind of my point right like
you don't want to make it easier for
your opponent to free up
he's like the bishop on h2 i would say
it's so important to
make sure that bishop stays hemmed out
of the game
so um definitely really interesting
uh we'll check out the other game to see
how it's going again i'm alternating
between the two leaders of the
tournament again if i see a really
interesting game going somewhere else i
might peek in but
for the most part i'm going to stick to
how the leaders are doing so this game
is progressing very slowly
um so he actually just goes back he
basically admits his mistake completely
which
again it looks kind of silly to play
like this but sometimes
it's kind of the sign of a mature player
that they can do this because
it's very difficult to admit playing a
mistake uh during a game and if you're
able to say you know what i made a
mistake i'm gonna go back
i think that's a really good thing and
black's position of course is completely
fine still
so b3 is played i don't really like b3
as a move in general you're covering the
square but
the weakness of the long diagonal tends
to be really really nasty in the long
term
so i would say that i'd really prefer to
do without a move like this so i think
white could have just
you know again taken a page out of
black's book a little before and just
improved pieces right make pieces better
so b3 rook c8 rook c1 and now we're kind
of just here so i think that
black's actually playing a little too
slowly they're clearly
not so familiar with the position and
they're kind of just trying to
figure out what to do which explains
this but i would say the important thing
here is that especially in a 15 minute
game
it's 15 moves and you've already used
two thirds of your time you have to get
moving
um the good news is i really like this
move for him
because i feel like if the bishop moves
then you have to deal with takes takes
ideas
so maybe the bishop has to go to d2 but
it's very passive there so you're seeing
this move b3 already haunting white
because if the palmer back on b2 bishop
g5 would be a good move
but because the bishop the pawn is on b3
with this knight loose you have to
probably
defend it with something like this maybe
so
yeah so i would say that this is already
like black still doing quite well and
again i think this move is just not
great
so white trades which is sensible but it
does allow bishop here and
i think black's position has just become
really easy keep in mind when you have
you're dealing with an iqp position if
the position simplifies too much
especially with minor pieces trading
um the iqp just becomes a worse of a
weakness the longer it goes
um because keep in mind an iqp by itself
is not necessarily that bad
it's just it depends on the situation
and the more pieces get traded
the more things simplify the more that
pawn um
just becomes a weakness whereas if you
have lots of pieces on the board and
white's using their extra space that the
isolated pawn gives them
it can even be an advantage to have it
so it really depends on the type of
situation you're dealing with
but i would say that here definitely the
black's the one who's uh
in the driver's seat as far as they have
a comfortable position however time is
going to become a factor they have less
than five minutes
their opponent also hockey uh also
doesn't have that much time
so i'd say this is going to be a pretty
tense game uh but
we'll again check back on it i don't
think there's too much action going on
let's check out this crazy game with uh
the open king side so yeah here d4 was
finally played and knight takes which i
think is a good decision
again note how you cannot take with the
pawn due to bishop b4
um but i don't even mind taking with the
knight because i feel like now you're
gonna get
uh a lot of stuff so here you're
threatening knight takes d4
followed by bishop before again so black
white has to contend with this in some
way
um you could think about even just
taking this knight you could think about
knight e6 there are so many options here
uh that it kind of makes it difficult to
choose honestly he chooses just a castle
the problem with castling is that you're
kind of castling into the fire here
because i think that these pawns
are just so menacing now
[Music]
in this game also you notice both guys
are taking their time they're both under
five minutes
which again in a 15-0 game is a serious
business right because you can just lose
on time
but here i think the move knight e5
makes a lot of sense um
and then it's just gonna be tough for
white i think because you have these
kind of moves like
even though it might free the bishop
someday f3 might just checkmate you
at some point uh and if you try to play
f3 yourself then first of all you're
walking into this pin
and also you're walking into this so i'd
say that a move like 95 just kind of
calls to be played and i think when
you're low on time you have to be
somewhat practical and
if a move looks that solid and that nice
you probably should just play it and not
overthink the position too much because
i think that
you know the more you overthink here
especially when you're getting low on
time
uh the rougher it can be
um but you have other options too i mean
moves like queen f6 are definitely not
poor
and they make a lot of sense i would
almost say like between 95 and queen f6
and maybe a couple other moves
it's more important to decide on one and
play it quickly than actually think a
long time here
in a short time control game um
just because again like you just don't
have that much time to worry about all
these decisions and it feels like these
guys are agonizing over
each of these decisions i would say that
it's very important
when you're playing this kind of time
patrol you want to
reserve your time for those key moments
where it's really important you get the
right move and this is a mistake we all
make it's not like when i play i
perfectly manage my time believe me but
i would say like a moment like this you
just should not be spending all your
time you should be thinking about queen
here knight here
there's no knockout blow it's not like
bishop takes h3 gives checkmate here at
least i don't think so
so it's like you you really have to
think about okay just improve my pieces
there we go queen f6
i have no problem with the move the only
thing i have a problem with is he spent
like two minutes on it or more
um i think that that's uh just a risky
thing to do and now he has under three
minutes for the rest of the game with no
increment
um and again if later he is this
decision to make that's not so easy it's
going to be he's going to miss that time
um so i would say that here i like
black's position i think this bishop
shut out of the game is really bad i
think that white has a weaker king
but i think the time situation by itself
makes this game a lot closer
um but white also has to be careful here
because this is a move where
if they're not careful maybe they just
end up just losing
so i don't know i mean my temptation is
kind of to simplify the game like try to
take
maybe bring this rook out somewhere or
even think about bishop here just trying
to trade off those guys i i'd be nervous
about trading
but i feel like if you buy yourself time
to kind of do this maybe you'll be okay
in some future life but honestly
i think white's situation is just really
difficult
so it's not like i think they have an
easy move they play rook d1 which is
perfectly sensible
but it also doesn't do that much and i
feel like after i move like 95
black's just doing extremely well here
but once again black has to play quickly
rook 88 is also reasonable
trying to target this pawn uh no problem
with this move at all
um
yeah i mean black black's really just
doing very well here it's just the time
that's the potential issue so probably
rookie one is
is kind of a reasonable move and maybe
then f3 though can come into play
i understand it lets out the bishop but
with this king this week it's uh
really asking for trouble all the time
so maybe some combination ah if rookie
one you also have knight takes and then
bishop b4
uh and i think winning the exchange is
pretty good like
after e5 maybe you're allowing counter
play nah
ooh f3 that can't be a fun move to have
to play
but he's basically saying you have a pin
here but you can't use it and in the
meantime i'm just going to solidify my
position and try to do this
um but i would say that this is also
kind of a sad move because here
now all of a sudden h5 g4 becomes so
nasty
because you have to do this at some
point you can't leave yourself pinned
forever and the second that happens
h5 g4 is just like uh
like get me out of here you know
um so i would say that this is just sued
so dangerous for white
uh but once again it's still a difficult
position
black stacks ticking so anything can
still happen for sure
and actually there's some dangers for
example of h5 king here if g4
immediately you do have this capture
followed by trying to take here
so it's maybe not super simple so i'd
say king h1 is almost certainly has to
be your move you have to get out of this
pin
um and then the idea is that on g4 you
can take so the question is does black
have a
nicer way to do this um again i
definitely like improving the knight
first and maybe trying it then
um that's definitely one option
it goes with king h1 staying up on the
clock which is very important
and now 95. very logical
yeah and the problem is white house to
find moves now which is maybe the
hardest part of this whole thing
so maybe it's sensible to try something
like this to try to throw in this check
to at least put a piece in the way
and a bishop takes pawn takes maybe your
bishop uses the e4 square or you at
least have this f pawn blocking
everything
um i don't know i would probably try
something like that so i think bishop c2
the problem with bishop c2 though you
might allow this
that's pretty nasty i have to admit so
white actually has a
tough decision to make here maybe
queenie two first and then trying to do
this it feels very slow though and the
queen on e2 might come back to bite you
because it's on the same files the rook
so you can see though how like how
difficult it is for me to even
like find good moves here it's just such
a tough position
uh and again it's all made it's all
because of this guy right
because you can play here but then g4
might just murder you
uh because if takes takes now you're
just getting cracked on all those
squares
uh it's basically just like a really
strong king's indian because unlike in
the king's
indian white has nothing on the queen
side so it's almost like a free attack
here
so knight goes back to c2
uh i mean i can't say i like this move
but at the same time it's hard to
criticize when the position's so
difficult right like this is
a very understandable type of thing
where you're like all right i just
don't want to deal with life you know so
black's playing knight g6 i assume with
the idea of play g4
so once again i feel like this is very
very difficult
for white and black's also caught up on
time notice how white black's actually
up on time now
and i think that's going to be really
significant to the position
so bishop g one's played trying to at
least fix that guy
so hey he fixed his bishop honestly
that makes you a winner in my book man i
mean i know this is a horrible position
but
okay you probably have to take with the
king so you could at least try to run i
think now g4 is just gonna be
lights out yeah here i think you have to
tear
here and then maybe even takes and then
try king f2 to e2
it looks really bad though i mean this
is not not a
not a kind of survival you want but
probably you had to try
because i think that if you leave the
key in this corner it's just going to be
bad news so he goes for this
he takes takes i mean the rook comes to
h8 i think it's going to be lights out
because
the problem is yes you have this but
black's in control over when you open
the position that's the problem
that when you have a position like this
black is the one who's in control
and it makes life so much harder so here
black has a choice but i couldn't even
allow the end game by the way the end
game is probably crushing because you're
still trying to
mate but black decides to keep the
queens on the board and probably that's
reasonable as well
uh the knight on e5 is too strong the
rook's coming here
yeah i mean this is just going to be
over probably black should just keep
things simple and just play rook ha
don't even bother taking on h3 although
taking on h3 looks
perfectly good i would say like don't
bother right just make sure no accidents
happen
uh queen h4 also looks quite good
um really at this point it's just a
matter
making sure you don't mess it up so g3
is probably a good move here
um you could of course trade but i don't
think there's any reason to
yeah this is just nice
and white's also going to lose on time
this is a problem when you have a
position like that
you don't want to play too fast as white
because you might just mate yourself
yeah i don't know
yeah so this should be the end
okay i mean he's allowing queen f3 which
maybe isn't necessary but even f3 here
it's probably too strong
um this definitely was not necessary
though
okay he takes and plays for gage too
this is also oh yeah
this is plenty good enough f3 comes next
this is over or doubles
threatening this mate really nice play
by black i have to say this was really
really beautiful conversion um
and just really really nice play um
overall by black in this game just you
got once they got an f4 they were just
merciless with the attack and just
really really
really really nice play okay
so we have 46 seconds to the next round
so jay josh is in the lead with
hockey uh ended up winning that game
uh vinnie h2o is in third place with two
and a half out of three and then we have
aaron sunboy with
two out of three jay jonathan with two
out of three and chest logic also two
out of three
and i guess moving hoax had a buy but
they also have two out of three as well
so again still a close tournament we got
two rounds left
we've played three out of five and the
next round starts in 15 seconds
so let us see
so almost certainly we're going to have
hockey against jay josh and we're going
to keep an eye on that game
um and then we're going to have vinnie
h2o playing as well with two and a half
so they could if the top two players
draw
vinnie could catch up to them this round
so let's see how this game goes
so we have e45
um petrov okay
yeah the petrov ever since uh fabiano
played it a lot against magnus in their
match
has become just really popular and it's
kind of interesting because he plays the
petrov and is known as kind of a drawing
weapon like you play
you have to know lots of theory but it's
just so solid and so tough to crack
um but it also was amazing to me how
many of the games became really sharp
and interesting even if white traded to
an end game early
like i remember there was some game
where wesley so i think it was against
fabi played the line with like
queen e2 queen e7 and then d3 bishop g5
or
some kind of endgame line which is like
really really dry
and even even um magnus played that and
even though it was an end game
they still got some crazy position uh
like actually my favorite
game of from the uh
carlson caruana match ended up in an end
game that looks so
harmless and then all of a sudden the
game just exploded so
um so i think the petrov even though
it's still
some of the positions can be dry it's
kind of gotten a revamp and a lot of the
positions at least to me look
very very interesting so d4 d5 bishop d3
bishop d6 so yeah there are two main
approaches you can play with bishop b7
knight c6 with idea on c4 you play
knight b4 this is one way that's kind of
solid
really just super solid really tough to
crack way and then bishop d6 tends to
lead to more combative positions
um so it looks like we're gonna see that
so here
castles castles and then the idea is
white usually plays with c4 c6 and then
there are different options you can play
with queen c2
um you can play with takes here and then
knight c3 type ideas you can play with
rookie one
so there are just numerous numerous
options um
that white can choose from and again
they all lead to different types of
positions
when i was an e4 player which was
already over 10 years ago
i used to really like these systems with
here here and then
takes a knight c3 and you try to get
rookie one rook b1 and you kind of
they often led to a pawn sack they were
really really exciting positions um
so that was always my particular
preference but honestly there are so
many different lines you can try
so rookie one is one of many
but knight retreating feels a little bit
sad to me i don't know if this is uh
a theoretical or not i think usually
there's all sorts of systems like white
can play
there's some ponzac i think with the
bishop coming here i don't remember
these lines so clearly it's been a long
time since i looked at them
you can also play with bishop f5 i
believe and there's even lines with f5
sometimes maybe not immediately but
there are definitely lines where this
occurs and again it's just really
complicated uh really interesting
stuff but net f6 is usually a sign that
something's gone wrong it doesn't mean
that you can't play with knight f6 right
but you're usually kind of withdrawing
from the center you're not claiming you
did anything with this knight push so
you're just going back
so there are lots of lines with knight
f6 in the petrov but usually
it means that black's playing a little
safer they're surrendering more
territory
but i doubt that this could be a
horrible move right because you're still
it's still very solid you're still
controlling the center
so white decides to go with c5 which is
always a committal decision
because one of the nice things about
having the pawn here is that you always
can put pressure on the center so if you
play a move like knight c3
you're putting nice pressure on the
center and if takes takes the bishop on
c4 is such a monster hitting this pawn
you have knight e5 coming in
you're not really afraid of those iqp
positions
so the most c5 again it doesn't make it
a bad move but it's a very committal
decision because it means that
you never can put pressure on this pawn
again and you either
play this to play for two things you can
either try to do this but honestly it's
very slow in a position like this i
don't really like that idea
and the other thing is you're basically
trying to cramp black so you're
basically saying look if your bishop
goes here it's very passive if it goes
here maybe i pin your knight and you
have issues with your knight
and i think that's what white's going
for here but i can't say that
c5 was the first move that occurred to
me but again this could be theory that i
just don't know
these are not lines which i've played
too much of
uh but c5 to me doesn't look necessary
like i think that white could play
knight c3 white could play bishop g5
and just kind of put pressure on the
center whereas this move almost takes
pressure off the center which i'm just
not a big fan of
so probably the bishops should go back
to c7 i think bishop e7 is just really
passive
maybe it's playable but to me that's
like a sign that you're kind of like
yeah
my position is kind of sad um bishop c7
i think's the more ambitious move which
is what he goes for
so now i think the proper setup is
trying to get this bishop out followed
by night out
um so you have a little space at some
point you're going to want to play b6 as
well
probably to try to free up a little bit
more room or force white to try to do
something like this
so white actually prevents bishop g4 for
this reason
so that now these pieces are more
cramped but i definitely think a move
like b6
could be seriously considered in these
positions because if if b4
a5 you can't play a3 because of takes
so i think that b6 is definitely a move
which i would be considering very soon
if not now
um like you could have even played it
here right like this would be i think a
very reasonable move
instead he goes this route um and i
definitely think that
like bishop e6 is again very solid as a
move but i would really really be
tempted to want to break apart these
pawns as soon as i can
because the second this bishop moves
white can at least keep these pawns kind
of solid right
whereas here i would say that
it's a lot harder to do that because now
now you can just do this and it's just
really nice whereas if you play b6 here
you can't play b4 a5
a3 and i think that if these pawns get
broken up it's going to help black
immensely because then your space at
disadvantage is not really a thing
but black's also playing just very
sensitive sensible moves white's
expanding on the king's side
uh queen side so yeah at least to me
this is just not the time for b6 if
you're going to play this way there's no
real reason to play b6
um but at the same time i don't think
white's doing anything too special
but you can see how this bishop money
six is just a little bit passive right
it would rather be out and uh on a more
active square
um but yeah i definitely would have
tried b6 at an earlier point
when you could have really cracked at
those pawns
um but here it's kind of an interesting
decision
because i think black can still play
with a5 and i don't know even rook b1 is
an option for white but basically
white's just trying to say look
your c6 pawn is always going to kind of
be a weakness and
because of the bishop on e6 you really
can't generate any active counter play
um and i don't know this might just be
the case like
this is one of those positions where it
feels like black needs something else
like if black had
knight e4 and f5 in then all of a sudden
life is okay you just improve your
pieces you have a plan of pushing on the
king's side
but here there's just no real active
plan so i think because he missed his
chance to play this earlier to bake
about the pawns
now the life is just going to be kind of
annoying because you're just going to
have this less space forever
and you just don't really have any kind
of active counterplay that i would like
so already it's kind of difficult
decisions again i
probably think you have to play with a5
um
just to at least give yourself a little
bit of room at least make it so that
you're not just kind of suffocating but
um it definitely looks like a difficult
position this bishop on e6 is just
really a sad piece honestly and
not having active counterplay is never
fun
as far as what black's idea should be
probably something like a5 maybe and
then
i would even consider something like
this knight here bishop here in 96. it
looks very slow but the idea is
bishop on d7 will guard this pawn the
knight on e6 can maybe jump
so you're at least getting some kind of
active kind of play and the 96 also hits
white's only potential weakness so
something like this
makes a lot of sense to me but at the
same time it's very slow and it's a
little bit passive
um whereas white can just kind of enjoy
their position they can
slowly improve their pieces they can try
to expand on the queen side
even hops like this are kind of
interesting sometimes
maybe
[Music]
i don't know
plenty of options but i definitely think
rookie 8 is a move you can play here and
looks okay why don't we check in quickly
on the other game just to see how it's
going and again i'm mostly sticking to
the p
to the leaders but
uh so you'll see vinnie h2o yeah all
right so this game
already had a lot of stuff happening
wait a second so c4
so vinnie is in third place at the
moment and chest logic i believe is two
out of three
so c6 so we have this line which is
already very sharp
um yeah so this i don't know how this e5
line goes i thought that white's
supposed to just play here now and then
just take but
maybe i'm wrong i don't know again i
it's it's harder to keep track of all
these
um but okay taking is of course uh quite
an okay move takes
bishop check knight back to c3 bishop b6
so we're even material
both sides have slightly weak pawns but
i would say black at the moment looks
more active to me
and that's kind of what i would go by
who's more active also i would say that
this this b3 weak square is going to be
really significant here and this pawn is
just not weak enough
so already i kind of um
i'm kind of uh opposed to this
so e3 97
yeah e3 is also a little bit of a
passive move for my taste like
it's already kind of a difficult
position but i feel like you have to try
to get like some kind of counter play
like
maybe even e4 and try like some kind of
weird pawn sack or bishop f4
trying to at least dislodge this bishop
i would consider very strongly here i
don't really like white's position if
you play passively which is kind of what
he's doing
so it looks like vinnie just kind of won
this pawn but things are a little messy
with f5
wow yeah this game is getting really
weird so
definitely white has to be careful here
white could just lose by doing stuff
like this but
i guess they're trying to get counter
play in a bad position which makes sense
so i don't know bishop d5 is also a move
moving back is not like a legal but he
goes for the most complicated
option uh so if you just take back here
i guess bishop here to here and
your life is just kind of terrible so he
decides to
even opposite bishop position honestly
if you have a pawn on d3 and a bishop on
e4 it's still kind of horrible so he
goes for this bishop back here
takes takes and at the moment black's
still up upon him with a beautiful
knight here
i would say that this is already
probably winning
or very close to winning for vinnie so
overall really nice play this was well
calculated it looks like this bishop
takes c3 thing
um yeah i don't know who moved their
king in castle i don't think black's
castle
but yeah so it takes takes yeah i mean
this is just really really good for
vinnie i think like the rooks come to
the center and you're just up a clean
pond this pawn is just really strong
here
and benny is also playing very fast so
he doesn't have to really worry about
his time either
um yeah this is already just really
really bad for white so it looks like
vinnie is going to
probably go to two and a half or sorry
three and a half out of four if they're
not careful so we'll see how
the winner of this game goes so this one
ooh this does not look right
so he went for so he played rookie 8
which is kind of what i was suggesting
and then he went for a5 and now b5 so
b5 is kind of the move you have to
calculate every single move
because if you allow b5 at the wrong
time it can end up just really really
horrible for you
um but b5 can also just give away stuff
so it
really depends on the situation so here
he takes on b5 and allows c6 which to me
was counter intuitive i thought that his
idea here would be to take
and then if it captures then you play
here with the idea that on takes then
you take and i thought that that was at
least
somewhat playable um i don't know how
playable
uh but at least it looked possible and
after takes if takes back you can always
just take with a knight so
but he took this one and now after c6
i'm very worried for him so
this is never possible here because of
takes
uh so you have to go back and then takes
and then this pawn is just going to be
such a thorn in your side this knight
can't move
so i'd say a position like this unless
you have immediate play
unless you have an immediate way to win
back this pawn it usually means you're
just kind of busted because this pawn is
just so annoying
just ugh
yeah probably here it's just a matter of
being careful for white f4 is
a risky-ish move but at the same time if
you make it so this knight can never be
captured safely
it's probably worthwhile um so yeah
black i mean they have to try like rook
here and try to take and move and just
anything to win this pawn because
honestly if you don't win this pawn you
can almost resign like the game is just
going to be over
because it's not just an it's not just a
past pawn it just keeps all your pieces
just so passive
and you usually just can't play a game
this way so
yeah so i'd say very powerful play by
white and i'd be really really worried
if i were black here
and there are so many ideas like white
can just try to play slowly but white
even has ideas like bishop a4
say followed by knight b5 and all of a
sudden your queen
is almost trapped so i would say that
this is just so dangerous bishop c8 is
never a good sign
i understand right you're trying to
regroup your pieces a little bit but you
have so many nasty options for right
here
again bishop a4 followed by knight b5
does not look dumb at all
uh but white can also probably play this
simpler like even a4
and rook here something like this i
don't know maybe moving this knight
somewhere else
is is also possible um
you could also think about targeting
this pawn this pawn is now a weakness
right
um but i would say this is just a really
really difficult position for black
which means that if j josh converts
he'll be at 4-0
going into the last round which
obviously is
quite a nice feeling even though he'll
have to probably face someone half a
point back it looks like
but let's not jump ahead of ourselves
there's still plenty of game left
but also i would say hockey also has a
clock problem which is that he's almost
down to five minutes
and again no increment so it can be kind
of nasty so white just chooses to play
queen b3 which
it's just probably sensible right
because you're you're hitting this pawn
so black has to deal with this pawn and
then you can just improve your pieces
you don't have to get fancy with it
um i would say sometimes when people try
to go after these positions when they
blow it is when they play too fancy they
try to be too sophisticated and
sometimes just simple moves are good and
here you're taking advantage of the fact
that you can't take here
uh this knight ever you can't take this
pawn
um and taking advantage of the fact that
this is weak so probably
yeah the bishop has to go back to e6
black realizes that that's probably
correct
and now i mean white has all sorts of
different options like trying to play
for f5 is possible but it's probably not
even necessary like even here just the
move like rook c1 is probably decent
you have to watch out for moves like
knight e4 it's one thing i'd say with
the idea of takes takes in the discovery
but even there d5 is probably just bad
um so i'll be interested to see what
white
chooses again white can choose moves
like this and then trying to take but in
general
you don't want to make the position more
exciting you want to keep it boring
because
if you keep this position boring i think
that black's just gonna get strangled
uh for space so very very nice game so
far by white
uh this b5 idea against a5 is very
common but again this is why i wanted to
play b6 a5 really early in the game for
black
um that you notice that if you play it
later
it's uh a lot less effective so white
does just
indeed strengthen the position with rook
to c1
uh definitely a very logical course of
action i would say
so white rook to e3 is possible but
again i don't know that like this is the
type of idea you're looking for i think
you're just trying to press in the
center
and use your very strong pawn i don't
think you want to necessarily
go after
all of that so rook goes to c8
um
yeah i don't know it's it's a kind of a
tricky situation there are so many ways
to play uh one idea i would think about
is even a move like queen back
the idea of trying to play f5 and you
know make this bishop feel bad about its
life
um is one potential idea
but you have so many so many ideas here
again i i do like this
idea of putting a net on b5 i think that
could be kind of nasty as well
but again i think it's almost a matter
of taste at this point i i would rather
have the queen somewhere else like
honestly the queen
on f3 makes a better impression because
then you can target this pawn and
threaten f5 and you don't have to worry
about knight e4 with discoveries on the
queen
so yeah i like this approach i think the
queen moving out of the way of this
discovery actually makes a lot of sense
so yeah now this is a threat to trap the
bishop it looks like so probably black
has to do something about that playing a
move like g6 runs into something like
this
always so probably this rook just has to
move again so that the bishop has a
square
it's unfortunate to have to move back
and forth if you're black but sometimes
it's just necessary
yeah be honestly this queen if it were
on f3 i'd really like it because then
you're threatening this and this and
you're also keeping an eye on everything
uh but queen b1 definitely you just have
to be careful i guess there's this move
always
so if you take immediately i think f5
and probably it's going to be good for
white but after a move like this you
have to at least make sure this pawn
does not hang on you
um because even though you might claim
you have so much compensation who cares
about the pawn it's like well
you don't have to lose a pawn here your
position's so dominating that there's no
reason to kind of sack a pawn for
anything
he does decide to take it and again
sometimes this is sensible just in that
you know your position's already kind of
bad and you know that
life is not going to be great you just
change the position you just say look
i'll sacrifice material just so that
the position changes and hopefully it'll
be better for me
objectively though i don't think this is
a good idea because i think after f5
your position is just going to be really
really difficult
because that guy is going to be trapped
as far as i can tell and if you take the
rook i can simply recapture even with
the bishop for example
maybe not bishop because i let go of
this maybe rook
something like that i would also
consider take stakes by the way
probably it doesn't work because you
take take but
i don't know that pawn looks kind of
nasty
never win a morphe don't quite know that
one
do not quite know that one
so bishop takes a a3
so what f5 yeah f5 i assume is coming
right
um i think that it's only logical
follow-up
uh can blackmaker come back here for
sure i mean it's still not like dead
dead right like it's not like you're
getting checkmated it's not like okay
everything is just dead lost
uh but it should be an objectively one
position for white i believe and with
this pawn on c6 it's unpleasant i would
also say white has a huge clock lead so
i would say that black is very likely to
lose but of course
a comeback is always possible these are
rapid time controls blunders happen
um but i would say that again as long as
this pawn remains on the board it's just
going to be so difficult for black to
ever win
um and again in a position like this i
would say the pieces tend to be better
than the rooks
so one thing i would recommend for black
is you take this you take this rook i
think you have to right like he's
thinking but
you got to take that thing maybe you can
take here first it almost doesn't matter
you take yeah he takes the rook first
which is sensible probably the rook
should take that
uh again you could i would consider this
especially in a longer game but probably
in a shorter game it's not worthwhile
so he does this and then probably you
take this guys you don't weaken yourself
more
and then you can consider different
things you might just consider getting
the night out just
you know get your pieces out and then
hope your opponent doesn't mate you
ah he goes for this this might actually
be better
because now you don't bring the queen
out and you also maybe get rid of this
guy
uh but after pawn takes knight takes it
looks really really bad
ah thank you golden patio um
yeah people ask this to me all the time
like what um
what would my this is my rating on
leeches and and what would my rating be
over the board and the fact is that it
it's um it's almost impossible to know
these things like
there are so many like you know players
who are very very strong over the board
i would probably put myself in this
category like over the board i'm much
stronger than
online and especially in like online
blitz like
not not that i can't play obviously but
it's like my strength is a lot weaker
than
in over-the-board classical chess and
there are some players who are absolute
monsters at
online blitz but then they play over the
board they're quite a bit weaker
so i would say you can't judge based on
someone's lead chest rating how good
they're going to be able to board it's a
different thing
there obviously are similar skills it's
like a gm over the board is probably
going to be good on
you know will be able to be decent but
they're actually very different skills
uh and very different games so
i would say that you can't necessarily
judge that but if you're 1700 on leaches
blitz you know you're obviously you know
above the average player for sure and
you know but i don't know where that's
going to put you
with an actual rating josh better than
stockfish i don't know about this
but i'm glad you're enjoying the
commentary anyway
um yeah so we'll see so here again
it looks like whoa what happened
oh he didn't even take it so after takes
takes yeah i don't know why he's not
taking this piece
uh so here he uh maybe there was a
blunder somewhere
but i feel you can still take this guy
right because if takes
queen takes there's queen coming into c8
that looks pretty bad so
it seems like white unnecessarily sacked
the exchange but the position is still
crushing probably
uh even down the exchange these pawns
and these bishops are just so massively
strong but i i feel like white could
have gotten the same position
but like with an extra piece um so
knight a6 is maybe mandatory now
um i guess you can always sack the piece
right but it's like it's gonna be kind
of
the two bishops are gonna be way better
than the rook here but yeah i think you
have to play that move so he plays there
so now he's gonna try to probably take
here or maybe try to push
something like this but this has gotten
less clear than it was the problem is
that
black has only a minute and a half uh
and white has over
almost four minutes so that's a pretty
big disadvantage
uh also there are so many moves for
example the move bishop d7 might be
nasty now because the idea is if rook
takes then this rook hangs with check
so after bishop here he decides to take
the knight which maybe wouldn't have
been my choice
uh but yeah here it looked pretty good
because you're just going to take this
rook
and if it takes then here and if night
takes then you take and you're still
pinned up
um so it looks kind of nasty but i would
say that this is definitely like
it's it feels like white has having to
win material back all of a sudden
whereas before if they had just taken
the piece
it would have been a lot simpler uh
queen takes a8 is also possible by the
way this is a good spot
um takes queen takes takes king here
takes but i
uh wait is that the right yeah yeah but
i feel like then there's checks at the
end so i feel like you're allowing a lot
of stuff that way
uh maybe you have a different way to do
it but i would say because this is with
check at the end and your king is open
sacrificing your queen is not necessary
or probably best so he goes for this
is that queen trapped wow i did not see
that at all
that's where stock fish would be better
than me it wouldn't it would spot an
immediately
wow this queen's just trapped that's
nasty
i guess it's not surprising when you
have pieces this good right like
it's one of those things where even
though black blunted the piece my
general instinct told me that
or sorry white blundered the piece it
seemed like my instinct told me that
black should still be
dead and i didn't see this but it
sometimes happens that you know you know
when your pieces are really great that
there's always some tactical win but you
still have to find it right it's easy to
blow it with maybe taking here too early
or taking um
or playing this too early because even
this was less clear but he did a nice
spot rook c6
trapping the queen really unexpected um
so he goes for this notice how you can't
um you can't take the pawn due to
checkmate
and again you have lots of ways to do
this queen h4 should be plenty good
enough
and you're just going for mate sometimes
going for made is best technique because
you just win
yeah it takes here or queen check yeah
it should be over
and also he's flagging so
okay this was not necessary but
wait what yeah okay come on like just
mate like why okay we made it all right
good
um so there's one game left
going and it is indeed chess logic
against vinnie h2o so
yeah jay josh with the lead i always
like when josh is leading the tournament
so let us see this game so this was uh
oh vinnie
didn't do this so smoothly so yeah this
position i think
he was really just doing quite well
ah but he gave back his pawn this was
the problem so yeah here you should have
some way to hang on to this pawn i
thought but maybe you can't
um but i would still say that black's
the one who's doing extremely well
even though you're not going to be able
to pawn anymore just due to the better
king the better structure the better
bishop
but yeah this was maybe not smart i
think he was depending on this and then
this tactic was available so they just
end up in this end game i still think
white's position is
black's position is um much better
actually rook d8 is really nice yeah
here and then i feel like this was
unnecessary this check on h4 i don't
think this accomplished much
but yeah black's still quite a bit
better grabs another pawn
uh white grabs a7 though uh-huh
yeah i don't know this feels like a pawn
you can take doesn't it
so yeah that might have been better but
he goes for this
which i think is really unclear like
this was maybe not the best course of
action
like for example pawn takes pawn should
almost certainly be a draw now so i
think that vinnie messed this up a
little
but time is getting into chess logic
keep in mind there is no increment
whatsoever
um so i think that this was maybe a poor
decision taking here i think would have
led to just a draw now maybe black's
doing well again although this pawn is
actually quite strong
um so maybe this is actually a little
bit dangerous
yeah in this position i might have tried
like putting the rook behind quicker or
something
um wow though
quite something so now yeah this pawn so
i think though you should try to push
immediately right because you can't
actually stop this pawn so easily when
the rook gets behind
so i would say that probably here rather
than going for the king up you should
probably do it with the
immediate lead so this is also probably
a mistake you can probably go back and
gain a few tempe and wait for the pawn
to go farther
trying to take immediately is kind of
tough uh now i think actually
also with the time like keep in mind
chess logic has 11 seconds
so i think that this this was actually a
pretty severe mistake you should
probably try to play rook here and try
to go back
you have an issue if rook here maybe
there's check and then push so maybe you
should try it this way
go back this way and then try to push
your pawn and i think that you have to
gain time with your pawn
wow he made it in time very nicely done
so what a game what a turnaround vinny
looked like he was out playing him but
he ended up uh getting mated just in
time so wow what a what a win and this
really
makes a big impact on the tournament
standings because if vinnie had won that
he would have been within half a point
whereas now josh uh
ensures he at least tied for first with
one more game to go
i'm going to refill my st i will be back
but one more game to go should be
exciting
so
so
uh
all right so uh let us see
it looks as if uh all right
go to this one oh it looks like jjosh is
disconnected all right i can go back to
this game later
alright so okay nope they're back so
let's see
so this is the game for first place so
let me just see this update is standing
so j
josh is in first with four out of four
and oh
and then a huge tie for uh second
through fourth so between hockey
aaron sunboy and chess logic 906.
so let us see how this one goes so
aha j josh like any true professional oh
no i was gonna say it was an exchange
french it's an exchange carol not the
same
but it's trying to play pretty safe
probably so because the draw clinches
him first but sometimes honestly
people try to play for a draw as white
in the last round of a tournament they
end up just kind of playing badly
so h3 a little bit safe like preventing
bishop g4
a little bit excessively i would say but
obviously this is perfectly playable
so we'll see how things go i mean again
like the they used to be like the setups
i knew were with bishop d3 and c3
against knight c6
you can also of course play with c4 is
more pano botfunic attack where you're
playing for
iqp and play more aggressively
there's also systems where you put the
bishop on f4 early is also playable and
it almost reminds me more of a london
system than anything else
because after knight c6 it kind of
transposes a bit to a london
but not if the h3 is a little bit
unusual for me uh not that it's
unplayable of course
so here actually g6 of course is
playable but there's also
like options of knight b4 i don't think
are stupid with the idea that
if bishop goes here you go here you
always want to trade that bishop and if
the bishop moves back then you go here
and all of a sudden it's like man that's
actually kind of annoying
because black gets a very active
position you don't want to have to play
here and then here and then black's
super active so
i would say allowing knight b4 is
actually not necessarily something you
want to do
because giving up the bishop also is a
little bit eh
um but of course it's all like just
minor stuff like obviously you can play
this way and it's perfectly solid and
perfectly fine
um
let me see so bishop g7 black's just
playing
developing normally um i would say josh
for how early it is in the game is
playing very slowly i'm wondering if
this is not a system he normally plays
so one of black's typical ideas in these
kind of positions is they play a bishop
to f5
even though yappini does it even though
you allow takes takes and the reason is
because after something like this you
put a knight on e4 with a pawn on e6
and even though you have those doubled
pawns and potentially a weaker king
that knight on e4 the secure or the
secure control over that square is
really nice
if white allows a bishop trader in
general just pretty happy
so sometimes white even blacks off with
the bishop
just so that you're left with this piece
here which can be at least a little
awkward
sometimes black does white does
maneuvers like this
so there are lots of ways to kind of
play this position but i would say that
this is
uh relatively normal still so far
nothing too crazy has happened um but
yeah a lot of the times allowing g takes
f5 can lead to disaster if your king is
open and if there's a way to take
advantage but as it is
um
someone is asking what is the elo of
josh friedel the elo of josh fidel is
about 25 50 a little over maybe
something like this i haven't checked my
email
elo in a long time um
but anyway i like answering questions in
the third person it was a lot of fun
so bishop f5 yeah so he does go for the
capture
it's interesting at least the more
double-edged positions i would say but
it also can be dangerous
um and i'd also like to note that black
hasn't castled yet so
playing with rook g8 and castling
queenside is at least not impossible
uh i don't want to say for sure it's
guaranteed i think castling kingside is
a very reasonable approach but
it's not completely unwarranted to try
to do that
um so knight bd2
so yeah e6 94 is definitely possible
[Music]
he just goes with 94 immediately also
very reasonable so i don't know you can
tell though that black's more familiar
with the position than white white spent
a lot of time has been unsure of their
moves and black's been playing pretty
quickly
to play bishop f5 quickly without you
know batting an eye to
allow this usually means you're
confident you know the position
and uh it seems like black's still very
confident doesn't mean that you know
black's gonna win or anything but
it definitely is kind of nice to be
familiar with the position
whereas josh i'm wondering if he chose
because he's 4-0 i'm wondering to try to
play too safely if he chose something he
didn't normally choose or if he just
wasn't
sure of the opening in any case knight
b3 makes a lot of sense because he wants
to put the bishop on f4 to control a lot
of dark squares
maybe at some point play knight c5 and
try to mix up the game
or try to push on the queen side um so i
would still say that black's position is
is good but white's doing just fine
after moving bishop f4 which he does
and now there's a choice of course you
can castle kingside or you can try to go
queen sled
in my experience in general trying to
castle queen side here can be very risky
because you're dealing with this bishop
and ideas like either rook c1 c4 someday
or trying to play knight c5 and then
trying to play b4 b5
kind of hit you pretty fast um
so i would say that castling queen side
it's possible but it always carries like
an element of risk
97 to g6 is not at all a bad idea uh
sometimes then the bishop drops back and
then i still try to play on the the
kings the queen side
but uh there's also ideas like knight c1
to d3 is actually not so stupid either
trying to secure the center a little bit
because sometimes you don't necessarily
want to allow the capture and
then you have to withdraw upon from the
center sometimes the pawn can become
weak he goes for knight c1 to d3
so yeah i mean lots of different options
obviously
um yeah 97 to g6
definitely is a reasonable idea probably
hmm quite a few different ones
sometimes ideas like this are possible
but they're a little one-dimensional and
it's not always clear the rook on g8 is
going to be that powerful
especially because your bishop just
doesn't have that many squares right
like your bishop would have to move but
the bishop here looks a little weird
maybe it's okay but
i don't know um black decides to play on
the queen side which definitely makes
sense
um because you have this strong knight
but the fact is that if you can put
pressure on this pawn
it is also fairly logical um
but again you always have to be careful
i'd say when you have a setup like this
this kind of pawn structure like it
looks like really powerful you have this
not on e4
it's easy to kind of get over enthused
about things like this
and i don't think it's like bad at all
but i would say that you have to be
careful because if the position opens up
especially in a way that's not so
favorable like you can end up with a bad
position because you have
all this looseness right like somehow i
get in c4 takes and i do this all of a
sudden your position is garbage right
so you have to be very careful when you
get this structure
um but it doesn't mean it's bad right so
here white black's trying to play for b4
another option for black by the way was
to try to put
this knight on c4 is also not an
uncommon idea
but i like his approach also just trying
to play for b4
and trying to put pressure
um so queen b6 played rookie one
so white's trying to pick up the pace a
little but i definitely think that b4
is reasonable um
i don't really know what rookie one does
i guess maybe rook c2 and you try to
safeguard your position a little bit but
another option for white is you could
try to play something like this to try
to exchange off a few guys maybe try
this to provoke a move like f6 at some
point
um or trade off the bishops which would
leave black's king a little bit bare so
i don't know something like this may
have been
maybe preferred for me
uh rookie one feels a little bit slow
because b4 is just coming so fast right
like it's it's just hitting you and then
you have to worry about this pawn being
loose
um but i definitely think black should
try to go for it right because otherwise
what are they doing
with all these moves um
yeah i mean it's kind of weird because
it's kind of like a normal carl's bad
structure where you have this against
this
and you're trying to play for this but
it is weird because you have this pawn
here which means that
sometimes there are ideas that you have
to be careful of doing because your
king's a little more open and other
times it's even better
for you because you have that better
control over that night normally that
night's not so secure and carl's bad
like you don't just plunk a night here
and are happy with your life right
so it's kind of an interesting uh
interesting difference you know so even
though it's kind of like a carlsbad
you have to be careful because it's
really not exactly the same
so once again i definitely think b4 is
the approach that's correct but
it's usually a good idea to think twice
before playing a committal move so i
don't
mind that he's thinking i guess i can
quickly check on other games while he's
pondering b4
um so the game for
second place between chess logic and
aaron sunboy i'm assuming
uh oh no hockey and aaron some boys
sorry chest logic is playing number one
oh this game already finished
oh no ah that's tragic so he fell for a
trick in the c3 system so
yeah bishop e5 and then here and the
idea is that on knight here
you taken and this bishop still hangs
that is brutal that's really sad
uh well i feel i feel really bad for uh
hockey that's uh
that's pretty tough that's not a fun way
to lose but
it's why it's kind of an illustration of
why even early in the opening you have
to be cautious about what you're doing
it's easy to play on autopilot
but you always want to check what are
threats what are checks what are tactics
and if you it's easy to keep your guard
down in the opening and then put your
guard back up when you're less familiar
but i'd say even early in the opening
keep that guard up make sure you see
your opponent's checks make sure you see
their threats
because losing like this is just never
fun
and you don't want to have to experience
this so i really feel uh sorry but
sometimes lessons like that are
important because they mean in the
future you're not going to do something
like that you're going to play more
cautiously
um but wow what a what a what a game
um
all right let us check uh back in on
this one
so he decides to play with f6 this
i'm less sure of um
for a lot of reasons first of all i
think that this is going to be so hard
to do with these pawns being loose
um so for example even if the bishop
retreats or something like this like i
really don't know if you want to play
this move
and if you're trying to do it just to
restrict the knights i think that it's a
little bit overkill because here
for example if i can ever move the
knight and play f3 you're gonna have
issues with the e6 pawn as well
so i'm really not a fan of this move i
feel like b4 was kind of asking to be
played
at least i didn't see a reason why it
wasn't good
um so i see someone suggesting queen c4
going for bishop h6 i'm assuming not
bishop h3 yeah i mean
b4 queen c1 is definitely possible but
even there i think i can take this pawn
try to play
maybe queen b3 and try to take your pawn
something like this
i still think it was quite playable for
black i could also play something like
this trying to take here if you put a
queen on c1 i think putting a queen on
c1 has its risks
by the way um because i think yeah then
if here then i have takes and
life becomes kind of complicated for you
so i don't know
i would say that maybe it was possible
but it also looked risky but this looks
like the wrong approach i think this
makes
i think f6 makes b4 worse because now
your e6 pawn is just going to be loose
forever so you have to deal with moves
like knight c5 randomly
and then you can't ever take it because
takes takes and this pawn hangs
um i would be
yeah this is not a turn of events i
would enjoy uh now knight c5 is still a
move here
and any kind of opening of the position
is going to be really rough for black
because this pawn is just going to be
loose
so i think you have to be so careful
with moves like this because it just
loosens your whole position
and now this is not stable at all so
um yeah i would say that even though
i'm not sure exactly what's going on
here i would say that i would be very
very cautious as black now i feel like
one wrong step and you can end up with a
position which where you just have all
sorts of only pawn weaknesses
and and your bishops also shut down so
in a lot of these
battles for the queen side you're only
playing you're playing without a bishop
um so i would be very very worried here
so many options here again knight c5
type moves i definitely would consider
um taking on b4 is also not entirely
dumb i mean normally this is a bad pawn
structure
but the fact is the board's completely
open now so you can deal with moves like
rookie six
whoa bishop d6
that is a bolt from the blue but does it
work
um so we have a few different options i
can throw in this capture at some point
and if knight takes d6 queen takes king
here knight here now granted
my structure is completely disintegrated
which is definitely in your favor
however
that's a piece um so maybe there's takes
d5 there's takes here this is quite a
move though
but i don't think it actually can work
that well like for example even if i
play knight takes d4 here
and then take this i don't know if
you've actually helped yourself so much
so this might be an example of actually
being a little bit too intricate like
this is a little bit too much
keep in mind i can also throw in this
capture right so takes takes knight
takes d4
knight takes d4 here you could take this
guy but i don't know
it doesn't feel like you've helped
yourself that much so bishop d6 is quite
a move
uh but i don't know if objectively it's
actually the strongest
um but quite a quite a creative move i
have to say i applaud just the
creativity even if
objectively i'm not so sure it's best
also by the way exchange sacks
galore are also in the air
maybe those aren't so good though but
okay so black decides to call the bluff
and says look you you don't have
anything
i am taking this piece what a what a
cool game though to see
see i don't know i mean it's honestly
this position just looks like a mess
because
it looks like after knight takes here
i don't know this looks starting to look
quite good for white right
so he takes first which makes sense you
have to recapture that guy and then
knight takes
here you have this pin knight takes d5 i
mean
i think knight takes d4 was maybe the
appropriate response that looked
actually pretty good for black but this
i'm starting to think that this is just
bad which means that this is quite a
sack i mean
again even if knight takes d4 is good
against bishop d6 this is
quite a quite an idea
yeah so knight takes b4 so now you have
two pawns for the piece and you're gonna
get a third so three pawns for the piece
is already definitely bad and decent
right
but you also have this knight which how
do you deal with this knight
because there's no rook defending it
like this is obviously you can at least
take the rook right
and this knight can't move so how
exactly were you gonna deal with this
yeah i think black got a little too
greedy i think taking the bishop on d6
was just a bad approach
um even giving up a pawn would have been
probably better than this
uh but i don't think it was necessary i
think knight dix d4 moves were really
strong
but again you can see how crucial the
moves are right like after bishop d6 you
have to really take your time
uh even if you're playing a short time
control game to make sure you get it
right do you take care first do you not
do you take this bishop do you not do
you take here or no
um and i think that you could even take
you can even take on a1 and then take
here bishop f8 take here and try to
stack it exchange i don't think that
works either
but it's definitely in the error and
something to consider but i think that
this
this response of knight takes d4 is so
important i think that's the key
but again i want you guys to notice the
only reason why this tactic even
remotely works is because you've played
f6
this f6 move because it weakens the e6
pawn because
it makes the whole position really loose
it just makes black's life kind of
miserable and it's the only reason why
this tactic
uh really works
so it takes takes knight takes b4 and
now i think that it's really bad so
someone mentions rook
a6 which is maybe a decent attempt but
first of all i could just take it but
even better i think
is i can check and then take with the
queen and that's a whole rook
um so i actually think this is just a
dead lost position
um so the real question is how does
black fight on because obviously you'd
rather not resign so
i i assume that you just have to move
the rook somewhere maybe allow knight
takes knight
and then try to grab this pawn but
it's even hard to do that because i'm
threatening this if rook b8
knight takes now you have a rook hanging
and a threatening check no
the problem is that not only are you
losing your piece back right
but your whole structure is
disintegrated you have this you have a
weak king you have a bad bishop
if if you were up a piece i'd say okay
you know it's it's an
interesting unclear position right
because you at least have a piece for
your troubles
although honestly even a piece for this
would be probably not enough
but you're actually going to lose your
piece back the problem is you lose the
piece back and you still have all these
positional deficiencies and the king
the deficiency with your king um i think
this just makes this position
completely unsalvageable but again these
guys are have shown to be really
resourceful players
so we'll see what black comes up with
this is i would say he should have
thought a little bit more about taking
this piece but i'd say now is a good
moment to use up some time to find at
least a way to play on
um because you have to five some
form of counterplay so one option i
might consider here is actually just
playing
king h8 so the idea is that you give up
this rook but this night but of course
then i can take
so you give blake a wide choice and this
is actually part of my idea
sometimes it's easier to play when we
have only one option right because it's
like well
i'm not sure what's going on but okay
this is the only move that makes sense
but you play here they can take this
knight they can take here they can take
here
it at least gives them options and my
idea is that if they then take like this
i at least have knight g5
trying to disrupt you a little bit so
that if you take then you kind of at
least fix my structure a little
um so i would at least think about
trying to play
king h8 so he plays bishop f8 so he's
trying to force the hand trying to force
knight takes but i think knight takes is
what white wants to play anyway
um so knight takes c6 is just a really
annoying move because it not only
um does a lot of damage but it also
threatens the move knight
e7 check winning the queen so this is
just really really nasty stuff there
probably are other wins as well knight
takes d5 i would suspect wins
because you fork the queen and this pawn
with check
that probably is completely crushing um
queen takes c6 is kind of a simple way
to win if you want to play the end game
you'll just have endless options as far
as how to win and the key is just not to
screw it up and not to use too much time
right you're playing a
minute game with no increments so i
think knight takes c6 is maybe the
simplest
there is rook a6 you have to watch out
for but you have many antidotes to this
for example even an id 7 check if you
have to
bishop takes queen takes is still
completely
crushing but knight takes here looks
like really strong because that then
you're just gonna take here
and the king is just gonna be hosed
you're just gonna take here
it's just too much hanging too much
looseness he decides to take on c6 which
is reasonable i think
this is the best try um
to try to at least force them to trade
yeah he does it this way but now i think
you can just start
gobbling up these pawns and then go
after black's king which is
obviously atrocious um so maybe queen
takes d5
is a good move here so now you're
threatening knight e7 check
screwing this and you're also just
trying to take everything and you're
keeping black pins so
queen takes d5 i like he takes on f5
probably good enough
um i definitely like taking on d5 though
to create the additional threat so here
i'm guessing it's still also dead like
probably you should try taking but
it's pretty pretty horrible
uh but again you know there's no reason
to give up here it's short time control
game so he tries to make threats rook a2
the problem with this stuff like this is
that even if you have to just play rook
f1 you're not really doing anything
um so rook f1 something like that
but probably as good a try as any
honestly like this is
this is a good attempt so probably rook
f1 is the most sensible
just keep everything up keep everything
at bay keep everything guarded
um i'd say this makes the most sense to
me
you could also move the f3 knight so
moves like this are actually not so
stupid with the idea of coming in
feels a little fancy but it also looks
quite strong
um i'm sure you have many ways to win
that's that's sometimes the part of the
problem like if you have
many ways to win sometimes you can use
too much time trying to think of them
like you notice josh is using his time
here which is wise but at the same time
you have to watch out you don't just
burn it all
so rook f1 most sensible choice i think
yeah i mean honestly a position like
this i feel like the way you don't win
this is not by like not being the most
decisive but by just not
like screwing it up by like oh i
blundered this so the most important
thing is you take pawns when you can
you weaken your opponent's king and you
don't let your opponent get to your king
at all
you basically just keep your king nice
and safe you take as many pawns as you
can
and quite honestly like probably your
opponent will blunder at some point
because the position's so hard to hold
there are some positions i think you
have to play really precisely to win
because there aren't that many paths
but a position like this i feel like the
most important thing is just
take your opponent's pawns leave their
king weak don't screw it up
you know keep your king nice and safe
and that's exactly what he's doing he's
not trying to mate his opponent as fast
as possible he's just trying to
capture pawns and win the game and i
think this is very sensible
so yeah i mean
there's nothing really for black to do
it's maybe you can try bishop d6 and at
least pretend to play actively but quite
honestly there's
there's just nothing there's no even
back rank trick i can even see
um but i would at least try it you know
you have to
if you know you're gonna lose anyway at
least lose playing active moves i'm sure
that there are wins by force after this
for example knight here probably should
win the game
but i would at least give it a try uh he
plays rookie 2 which i guess makes sense
trying to cover some squares but moves
like 95 for example look completely
killing
you can also just go after the d5 pawn
probably in some way
but i don't know an a5 looks just really
strong right because if knight takes
knight takes you're just threatening
queen f7 check
the black king is is bare and you're up
uh two pawns knight g5 he chooses also
plenty good enough
so now if knight takes queen takes you
can just collect this pawn this is a
nice way to do it
so i'd suspect josh is going to be 5-0
this tournament
so really really nice really really nice
event by him
so um
we will see
yeah so black takes it probably they had
to but this is pretty dead
um i guess we can check back to make
sure but i mean we'll see
are there any other kind of interesting
games going on
so there's only one other game this is
the other game between chess fans and st
louis and five swat
um whites up upon this end game it's
fairly fairly clean pawn i would say
but still some work to win right like
the king will probably chase the rook
out
then the rook maybe comes in somewhere
and i'd say there's still plenty of work
left to do here it seems like it's just
moving back and forth though which seems
kind of weird
um but i guess oh they have no time 34
seconds against 310.
black declines to draw so basically
black's trying to flag white here
uh but okay objectively white with the
extra pawn
should be doing pretty well uh even with
the knight against the bishop probably
the knight should reroute itself and
then maybe
try to get the rook in the game uh but
let's check back to make sure that this
that josh wins the event here because
there is two minutes left of course
things can happen
yeah so here again it's there are
probably force winds all over the place
but the key is that you don't screw it
up so here
queen check is the easiest win because
then you can play either knight here
check or knight here check and you win
the queen by force and this is what he
plays i think this should end it
he's up on time as well so yeah just the
key is just bishop here knight check and
then you win the queen
that should be the end of the game uh
there's also choices if bishop here you
can probably check and win the rook
but obviously winning the queen is a
little bit better
so i'm assuming that he either resigns
here or the gate is over and a couple
moves
um let's just check to make sure
yep so now will he choose queen g4 check
will he choose 97 check
he goes with the winning of the rook
winning the queen was probably
objectively strongest of course
but this is plenty good enough this is
the thing like when you have a position
like this you don't have to find the
absolute
best 100 way to win you just have to
find a way that's clear and
being up a queen uh being up a rook for
a bishop and three pawns is plenty clear
so this should pretty much do it
so we'll see i mean obviously he has to
be careful not to lose on time
it reminds me i wonder how the other way
went i wonder if white actually lost on
time here
so this one rook takes that f4 i'm
assuming there was time yeah yeah so
here
yep just no time so even though white's
up white was up
uh some material he just gave away his
rook because probably pretty moving
it's the problem when you don't have
increment time controls right like i
understand why they do it of course
because if um
if you have increment time controls it's
really hard to predict the end of an
event and stuff like that
but i would say that when you don't have
increment you risk this kind of thing
that you'll have games which are end
kind of stupidly
but it also it also means that people
have to manage their time right they
have to play
um they have to play quickly but they
also you know they have to take their
time at certain moments but they also
have to
choose where all right here i just have
to play fast and
um it's again how people used to have to
do it so
but i would say definitely that you have
to be careful not to get super low when
you're dealing with non-increment time
controls
so white decides to trade to the sun
game
quite honestly it's amazing black made
it this far but yeah he decides to take
the bishop by the way guys you never
have to take the bishop just
play king here check bring your king in
take the bishop when they're gonna
resign you know
but of course this is plenty good enough
and yeah i mean i suspect that resigns
will come soon
yep all right and the game is over
so let us see so the winner was josh uh
007 so congratulations always happy when
josh's win
uh aaron's son came in second and then
vinnie h2o came in third so again
congratulations really interesting games
really fun tournament i hope you guys
enjoyed the commentary um
i'm going to be uh the saint louis jimmy
rez for the next
week as well so i'll have a few lectures
tomorrow
uh on here uh so a couple
like a lecture for kind of um more
beginner type players a lecture for
slightly intermediate
and then a puzzles lecture and i'll be
doing a bunch of activities next week as
well for the club so
definitely stick around for those and
uh again thank you again for watching